looking over the mcu's Blockbuster
history it's pretty clear that the
franchise has a villain problem but
despite that we've actually seen some
fairly compelling criminals cause
trouble for Our Heroes here are all the
villains in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe ranked from worst to best in
the Dark World curse leads a prison riot
helps Malachi sack Asgard and kills
Thor's mother Friga he also leads the
battle against Thor in the film's climax
beating the Thunder God senseless with
his brute strength but even with all
that curse is little more than a
forgettable monster with no personality
Fenris hella's enormous wolf is an
undead Beast who tries to finish off the
Asgardian refugees toward the end of
Thor Ragnarok till the wolf's credit the
menacing green-eyed monster definitely
looks cool but sadly pheneres really
doesn't do much after hella animates her
beloved familiar he just sort of hangs
out and looks mean while the deaf
goddess interrogates a crowd of
scaredness Guardians in the final battle
Fenris tries and fails to kill the Hulk
on the one hand it's nice to see another
bad guy from Thor's Rogues Gallery fit
into the film on the other hand it seems
like the only reason Fenris is included
it is because the Hulk needed something
to tussle with during the climactic
final battle lafi is a powerful force in
Thor's corner of the MCU but we never
really see much of him in action King of
the frost Giants is the biological
father of Loki he has super strength and
ice powers but he's still no match for
the sneakiness of his own son Loki
manipulates events to get lopi to attack
Asgard and Thor but just as lauki is
about to kill Odin Loki takes out laufi
instead killing the frost giant king and
making himself look like a hero in an
unceremonious end Aldrich Killian turned
out to be the A-list bad guy in Iron Man
3 with Branton Savin shaping up his
little more than b-list versions with
the same Powers both are given their
superheating and healing powers by the
extremist virus and they both attacked
Tony Stark throughout the film but
neither is a match for Iron Man even
when he doesn't have a suit scorpion is
a pretty big deal in the comics but in
Spider-Man homecoming not so much his
most notable actions are complete
failures first when an arms deal is
interrupted by Spider-Man and then later
when he tries to get the Sinister Six
going in prison before being shut down
by the vulture basically he's just there
to make Adrian tombs look cooler by
comparison and when you're not as cool
as the vulture it's safe to say you
screwed up pretty bad somewhere along
the way it's easy to forget but yeah
spatrock the leaper is part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we meet the
French mercenary during the opening chip
hijacking sequence in the Winter Soldier
we get a breathless fight scene between
Captain America and batroc with cap
accepting batroc's challenge for
hand-to-hand fight without a shield that
truck holds his own though cap
eventually knocks him out but hey at
least he's a little cooler than this
version
Spider-Man homecoming gave us not just
one but two Shockers we meet the first
shocker Jackson Bryce says he's wielding
a shocker Gauntlet but after the vulture
kills him the weapons pass the Hermann
Schultz Schultz looks to be our main
shocker in the MCU and he gets one epic
fight against Spidey before being
sidelined shocker jumps Peter as he
leaves the school dance attempting to
follow the vulture the villain sends
Spidey blind to a school bus knocking
his web shooters off in the process so
why does Shaka rank so low because it
wasn't even Spidey who took him out it
was Pete's pal Ned who grabs a web
shooter and hits shocker distracting him
long enough for Spidey to Webb into a
school bus Baron von strucker led the
experiments on Loki's scepter that
created quicksilver in the Scarlet Witch
so he's definitely important but all
anyone really remembers about him is his
immediate surrender to the Avengers
during the opening of Age of Ultron
no surrender
I'm going to surrender in the end
strucker was just another Hydra goon cut
off his head and nobody really noticed
when the Destroyer shows up in Thor it
makes full use of every moment the
destroyer's giant powerful arms and legs
can crush or stop just about any
opponent and if they don't kill you it's
laser blast probably will we saw the
Destroyer kill a few Frost Giants then
lay waste to a small town in New Mexico
when Loki sent it to Earth hunting Thor
still it was no match for Thor when the
God of Thunder regained his power and
overcharged the Destroyer ending the
attack credits Sam Rockwell's unending
Charisma for Iron Man 2's Justin Hammer
not showing up at the very bottom of
this list as far as credible villains
are concerned Justin Hammer is an
absolute joke he runs an arms
manufacturer that's a rival to Stark
Industries except everything Hammer
builds falls apart the first version of
the war machine armor is basically a
Bare Bones Iron Man suit outfitted with
a ton of hammer weapons which works just
about as well as duct tape and
accessories to a car to summarize Sam
Rockwell is great Justin and hammers
still kind of sucks though Dr Samuel
Stearns doesn't actually ever call
himself the leader which is his
villainous identity in the comics but
the Incredible Hulk isn't exactly subtle
about The Eccentric scientist's Destiny
the last we see of him he's on the
ground is the hulkified blood he's just
pumped into Emile Blonsky drips into an
open wound on his head if a Hulk sequel
had come to pass we would almost
certainly have seen Tim Blake Nelson
return as the psychic and super
intelligent leader Nelson is perfect as
an obsessed scientist who doesn't care
much about the consequences of pursuing
his goals across ethical lines while he
never actually turns green on screen he
shows plenty of signs of a moral compass
in need of some fine-tuning he clones a
whole room full of banners blood without
Banner's knowledge or consent and he has
no problem with the notion of turning
Blonsky into Abomination and of course
in his final moments in the movie he's
seen smiling when any sane person would
be horrified in The Incredible Hulk
General Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross spends
the entire film trying and failing to
kill Bruce Banner and for much of the
film he's a relatively one-dimensional
military bad guy interestingly however
Ross is one of the few characters from
The Incredible Hulk to resurface later
in the MCU he became the U.S Secretary
of State and Captain America Civil War
pushing for the adoption of the sokovia
courts and even made cameos in Infinity
war and endgame setting him up for even
better bad guy stuff in films to come in
an effort to capture the Hulk humiliated
Soldier Emile Blonsky hits himself with
an experimental version of the same
gamma stuff that makes Hulks and hulks
except it doesn't turn him into another
hole instead he becomes the Abomination
a monstrous one note creature that looks
like a rotting troll yawn he lives
through the end of The Incredible Hulk
and is apparently in a jail cell
somewhere dark elf malekith had almost
no personality and basically existed as
a freaky looking dude trying to get an
infinity stone and Thanos already does
that way way better it's a shame because
on the surface malekith is extremely
formidable he even stages a surprise
assault on Asgard itself reaching the
city's defenses and later sets his
sights on Earth he put up a heck of a
fight against Thor in the Final Act of
the Dark World though the God of Thunder
still prevails Mickey rourke's Whiplash
was one of the many problems in Iron Man
2. despite some admittedly awesome
action scenes along the way Whiplash
never feels all that intimidating at
least after that epic attack at the
Monaco Grand Prix he's motivated by a
vague kind of boring backstory and teams
up with Justin Hammer who we've already
established kind of sucks and then there
was that odd obsession with his bird
tanelier Tavon better known as a
collector has a remarkably low-key
career as an MCU villain you might
understandably question whether he's
really a Villain at all look carefully
and you can see that he's pretty darn
evil as early as his first appearance in
a Thor the Dark World mid credit scene
we learned that one of his goals is to
collect all of the Infinity Stones but
probably just for bragging rights not
Conquering the universe but a closer
look at his expansive collection reveals
a whole lot of unwilling prisoners we're
fairly certain that if the collector
were ever given a more active role in
the MCU he'd earn a higher spot on this
list there's something intriguing about
the way he's been on the periphery of
the narrative most cataclysmic events
mystery surrounds Tavon including the
mystery of whether or not he's still
alive when Obadiah stain decides to take
out Tony Stark while Starks on an
overseas tour in the first Iron Man film
he contacts the terrorist organization
the 10 Rings led by Raza to make it
happen Raza keeps Stark captive and
proves an intimidating Villain at least
until Stark builds his first version of
the Iron Man suit and makes short work
of Raza soldiers Raza was Savvy enough
to survive and he tracked down straight
bits of Stark's armor and tried to cut
another deal with stain the problem
stain was more savvy than Raza and used
the Sonic taser to paralyze him and kill
his man despite his unceremonious ending
Raza is still technically the first
villain we met in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and a throwback to the simple
days of the MCU korath has a small but
memorable role in Guardians of the
Galaxy which provided one of the most
memorable moments from the movie's
opening scenes hey you know what there's
another name you might know me by
Star-Lord
who Star-Lord man though Star-Lord gets
the better of him Cora still puts up a
heck of a fight he also manages to
reacquire the infinity stone along with
nebula which sets up Ronan the accusers
near world ending attack on xandar
without korath Ronin would never have
had the infinity stone to begin with so
he certainly served a purpose he even
holds his own against Drax the Destroyer
for a while at least until Drax rips out
the cybernetic implant in his head
killing him hey at least he went out
fighting Andy Circus actually does an
extremely entertaining job with Ulysses
claw in both Age of Ultron as well as
black panther which gives us a
believable version of The Claw we know
from the comics and cartoons a character
who still has the potential to come back
after his death as a dude made of sound
waves hopefully the MCU will resurrect
this classic comics b-lister for future
super villainous action Walter Goggins
is a genuine Delight every time he shows
up on screen and his appearance in
Ant-Man and the WASP is no exception
sure Sonny Birch doesn't do much
compared to the likes of killmonger or
Thanos but he might be one of the MC use
most comic bookie villains ever as a
dealer in illicit technology Birches a
character that like the vulture operates
on the fringes of a universe filled with
magic Hammers and alien technology the
difference is birch is the kind of
sleazy Mastermind who rolls around in a
white and gold SUV conducts his illegal
business in broad daylight and commands
an army of nameless motorcycle riding
henchmen Birch is the perfect character
to have around to reinforce the idea
that there's more to this world than
Shakespearean gods and Magic space rocks
she might not have been the big bad in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 but the
Golden Goddess Aisha was able to cause
more than enough trouble for Star-Lord
and his team the leader of the powerful
Sovereign she commands a fleet of remote
controlled warships that come within one
shot of taking out the Milano following
an extensive Chase moreover the
post-credits scene revealed Aisha seems
to be responsible for creating Adam
Warlock a major player in Marvel's
Cosmic universe and someone we expect to
meet in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
if nothing else that makes her more than
worthy of a slot on this list the
jittery basically served as Cannon
Potter against Earth's Mightiest Heroes
in the final hour of the Avengers even
still they are a massive alien Army led
by those positively terrifying gigantic
Dragon ships at tour through Manhattan
their eventual humiliation
notwithstanding that shitari were more
than formidable enough to push the
Avengers to the brink in their first big
screen team up and when they returned
for the big final battle and end game
their only strength seems to be in
numbers and they were defeated just as
easily in Captain America the First
Avenger Arnhem Zola's appearance is
basically just an Easter egg in Winter
Soldier however the setup of having Zola
around for the first movie pays off in a
cool way he might not be a robot with a
camera for a head and his face on a
giant TV screen built into his Gods like
in the comics but what Winter Soldiers
big reveal lacks in robot bodies it more
than makes up for by making him
genuinely creepy anyone familiar with
Marvel Comics knew some kind of
villainous turn was coming for mordo and
Doctor Strange while he spends most of
the film as Strange's Ally the angry
sorcerer abandons his allies after
strange makes his bargain with dormammu
after the credits we see mordo become
the Nemesis he's long been in the comics
declaring there are too many Sorcerers
in the world he's bound to be a
challenging antagonist and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
plus he's played by chuatella geo4 the
oscar-nominated actor is not only a
superb performer but he's particularly
great in villainous roles the black
order are perfectly serviceable henchmen
for Infinity War they managed to hit
that sweet spot of being threatening
enough sent the heroes with a challenge
but they also provide additional room
for the action so that it's not just 40
people trying to punch Thanos at the
same time ultimately they're not so
threatening that they overshadow the
actual villain of the piece each of them
is distinct and Visually menacing
especially ebony Maul unfortunately most
of them don't actually get to do much
other than lose so that's a bit of a
drawback
in Guardians of the Galaxy Ronan was a
religious zealot who co-opted the Power
Stone to continue his crusade to wipe
out xandar but even without one of those
awesomely powerful baubles he's still a
heck of a warrior after all he laid
waste to Drax the Destroyer without even
breaking his sweat he also had the guts
to stick it to Thanos and actually
walked away from the Mad Titan without
much Consequence the Guardians were no
match for Ronan individually but luckily
Star-Lord was able to actually control
the infinity stone with the help of his
team his half Celestial powers and some
sweet dance moves all of those things
together and Star-Lord was able to blast
the bad guy into Oblivion ant-man's
Darren cross spent his entire career
trying to duplicate Hank pym's shrinking
formula but when he did it and created
the Yellow Jacket combat suit he didn't
realize his copycat formula was actually
messing with his brain making him
dangerously unstable that led to a
villain who was not only dangerously
unhinged but got some really cool fight
scenes the best of which was on a
child's play table Ant-Man and the WASP
super powered villain ghost has a lot
going for her visually her flickering
and phasing through objects is some of
the coolest looking stuff we've seen in
the MCU it's even better in the fight
scenes the shrinking and growing stuff
is fun but pitting that stuff against a
completely different set of powers makes
for some pretty compelling action since
she seemingly reforms at the end of the
film were obviously meant to like her
she has a sympathetic backstory as a
victim of Hank pym's egotistical past
but at the same time are also supposed
to like Hank so his part in ghost
backstory still involves him ultimately
being right none of this is too
surprising Marvel is full of bad guys
doing the wrong thing for the right
reasons but it does feel pretty clear
that ghost was horned into Ant-Man and
the WASP rather than building her more
organically still the effects are great
and Hannah John Commons performance
captures Ava's understandable bitterness
and Desperation effectively Die Hard
Comics fans know surter is a major
villain in Thor's world and Thor
Ragnarok however he appears only in the
opening act and destructive finale
that's not to say he's not important to
the story in Norse mythology the word
Ragnarok points to the apocalyptic
battle between Gods it results in a
world destroyed by fire while Searcher
is indeed the monster all-ass Guardian
spear Thor and Loki summon him to invoke
the Ragnarok prophecy this defeats hella
but at a price his attack decimate to
Asgard fumbling the city in the sky to
dust when Marvel asked Annette Bening to
play a villain in Captain Marvel they
probably didn't open with you're going
to be a giant green disembodied head
with a bunch of gross tendrils floating
in some kind of Goo that would be an
accurate description of the character's
physical appearance in the comics but
instead of the bulbous floating head
captain Marvel's creative directors
chose to represent the AI that rules the
cree Empire as a kind of psychic
projection everyone who communes with
the Supreme intelligence sees someone
different and in Carol's case the
intelligence appears as her Mentor
Marvel as viewers we spend a lot of time
I'm in Captain Marvel thinking the
scrolls are the bad guys once the truth
is revealed it's Yan Rog who's the most
visible villain perhaps in the future
we'll see more of the cree ruler giving
the Supreme intelligence a chance to get
a better spot on this list Red Skull
easily stands out as one of the most
original and terrifying baddies in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the First
Avenger He commands his own
hydro-branded Nazi division complete
with Tesseract powered weapons and has
his own version of the super soldier
serum making him caps physical equal he
vanished while trying to harness the
power of the Tesseract space Stone but
his surprise return is the guardian of
the soulstone in Infinity War only
served to remind us how great he was so
many years ago he might have just been a
disciple of dormammu but casillius was
plenty intimidating in his own right a
highly trained sorcerer who went rogue
left the ancient ones ordered to try and
take out the masters of the Mystic Arts
and nearly succeeded and Dr Strange
casilius manages to destroy two sanctums
but the ancient one's forces on the
robes and chose his prowess with magic
and a few excellent fight sequences
luckily a quick thinking strange man
manages to turn the tables and win the
day the tinkerer is exactly the kind of
character that the MCU needed for the
same reason that it was exactly the kind
of character that the comics needed
someone who builds all the gadgets the
bad guys use to fight the good guys he's
certainly not the focus of Spider-Man
homecoming but Phineas Mason is the kind
of quiet bad guy who makes the MCU feel
just a bit more real every great ruler
needs someone beside them to carry their
melting stick in Thor Ragnarok that job
goes to Topaz the sadistic and
unforgiving right-hand woman to the
Grand Master and she's a perfect match
for her eccentric boss while he Delights
in his games and Acquisitions topaz
stands nearby ready with his instruments
of torture always eager for the Grand
Master to melt people unfortunately for
the Grand Master topaz does not survive
Ragnarok and crashes while chasing Bruce
Banner Thor and Valkyrie during their
escape from sakhar topaz's service to
Grand Master is clearly not forgotten
and one of Marvel's shorts we see that
the Grand Master has built a modest
Shrine to his former assistant in his
new Los Angeles apartment of all the
impressive things about spider man
homecoming one of the most notable is
just how many characters the film pulled
in from the comics and the best minor
villain appearance by far is absolutely
Aaron Davis known in the comics as the
prowler in the film he's hilariously and
thoroughly unimpressed by Peter Parker's
enhanced interrogation
well I haven't knew your voice
I heard you got a bridge I know what A
girl sound like
it's one of the best comedy
entire MCU but what really makes it
special is Davis's mention of his nephew
as comic readers know Davis's nephew is
Miles Morales who eventually takes the
name of Spider-Man as far as villainy
goes Davis doesn't accomplish much
Beyond a failed arms deal hinting at a
future of the MCU that includes miles
though that's awesome sure the ravagers
aren't all villains at the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy plenty of them
sacrifice themselves to save xandar but
in the sequel we see a darker side of
these mercenaries when taserface takes
over yondu's ravagers everyone's still
loyal to yondu is rewarded by being
injected into space as their former
comrades laugh and wait most of them are
also more than happy to abuse poor baby
Groot and of all his survivors only
craglin refrains from trying to kill
yondu rockets and crew to say Escape as
villains the ravagers don't accomplish a
lot and without someone like yondu or
nebula supporting them they don't
provide much of a challenge to the
heroes but while they may be cannon
fodder they still give us a lot of
laughs their well-deserved beatings
provide some of the most fun sequences
and Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
Rock rumlow started out as a member of
Captain America's Strike Team and Winter
Soldier eventually revealing himself as
a Hydra agent when the attempted
takeover began he managed to survive and
resurface during the opening fights in
Civil War where he went toe-to-toe with
both cap and black widow before blowing
himself up in the event that ended up
driving The Avengers apart for a villain
that's a pretty good way to go dormammu
is one of the biggest villains in Marvel
Comics and surprisingly the MCU actually
kept the extremely powerful ruler of the
dark dimension relatively close to his
Comics counterpart Doctor Strange's trip
to the dark dimension was practically a
Steve ditko panel brought to life
dormammu is so powerful that doctor
strange had no chance of hurting him so
he had to outsmart him to save the world
trapping the villain in a Time Loop
where dormammu killed him over and over
until he was forced to bargain for his
freedom it makes for one of the most
clever finales in all of the MCU and
lands dormammu high on our list of
favorites after one final explosive
tussle with Gamora nebula joins the side
of the angels and Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 but that's not true of
every version of nebula we meet in fact
it's indirectly because of nebula that
Thanos gets to wage his final battle
against the good guys in endgame when
nebula goes back in time to 2014 to help
get the orb the nebula of that time
becomes aware of her the 2014 nebula
isn't reformed she's still loyally
killing anything and everything her
father tells her to as well as harboring
murderous jealousy towards Gamora 2014
nebula is pretty tragic even when she's
confronted by her heroic future self the
2014 nebula sees no way out she clearly
wants to be different but she ultimately
dies because of her refusal to change
even though the proof that she can
change is literally standing in front of
her when Marvel signed Robert Redford
for a superhero movie you knew it'd be
an interesting role and his turn is
Alexander Pierce delivered he's
introduced as the well-meaning secretary
of the world Security Council an old
friend of Nick Fury though it's
eventually revealed Pierce is actually a
Hydra agent leading their infiltration
of Shield pierce shepherded the program
designed to create the network
telecarrier system everyone is fighting
over in the Winter Soldier he also
planted bombs and the name tags of the
other Security Council Members which he
uses to brutally murder them when they
challenge his takeover he stayed evil to
the end too uttering hail Hydra with his
dying wrath after Nick Fury put two
rounds into his chest now that's a
villain
Ben kingsley's character in Iron Man 3
wasn't actually the real Mandarin and
they all hail the king one shot short
suggested the actual bad guy could still
be out there waiting to make his move
but that fake Mandarin still gave us the
chills at least until it was revealed
that he's really just an out of work
actor named Trevor Slattery who can
barely be trusted with a six-pack of
beer much less a gun still although it
loses some luster by the end the
Mandarin presented in the front half of
Iron Man 3 is one of the scariest
baddies in the MCU it might have been a
ruse but it was effective and you'll
never see me coming
when Thor suddenly marooned on the junk
planet's car he comes in contact with a
grand master in the comics The
Grandmaster is just an immortal dude who
loves playing games of any kind but in
the hands of Jeff Goldblum the Grand
Master becomes one of the weirdest and
funniest characters in the MCU here's
hoping we get to see a lot more of him
in the future oh maybe not as much as he
wants us to on any other world I'd be
like millions of years old here on sakar
[Music]
you have to respect where it all began
and Jeff Bridges Obadiah stain AKA
ironmonger set the tone for the villains
of the MCU in the first Iron Man film
Bridge's stain is positively slimy
betraying Tony Stark and inadvertently
setting his entire hero's journey in
action so really we can thank stain for
kicking off the entire MCU when his
assassination attempt on Stark and the
desert Bales stain eventually Dawns the
massive Iron Monger suit to try and
finish the job himself a lot has changed
since Iron Monger stalked the skies but
his final fight with Iron Man had a
brutal messy feel that really let you
feel the hate staying had for Stark and
it still resonates even in a world with
Heavy Hitters like Thanos prowling
around James Spader's chilling voice
brought absolute Terror to the metal
Menace that was Ultron with a near
endless supply of robot bodies and a
design that had comic bands geeking out
he exemplifies how technology can be our
greatest Scourge though Ultron does it
with a wit that only Spader can provide
verbally sparring with the best of them
like any great villain Ultron also has a
real motivation for his dastardly Deeds
looking at the facts Ultra spinal
determination that humans and
superheroes are what make the world such
a dangerous place makes its own Twisted
kind of sense the most amazing thing
about helmet Zemo in Civil War is that
he's just an average guy with no real
plans for world domination he's just a
man who wants revenge for the death of
his family and he's wise enough to
realize the best way to take out the
Avengers is to set them against one
another yes his plan does require a few
big leaps of movie logic but it was
refreshing to see a Villain Like Zemo
brought to life in the MCU he's a great
reminder that it doesn't take World
smashing superpowers to give Earth's
Mightiest Heroes a run for their money
Iron Man 3 is one of the most polarizing
movies in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
featuring an epic fake out that reveals
guy Pierce's Aldrich Killian is actually
the villain behind a mysterious rash of
bombings and terrorist attacks sweeping
the globe the secret weapon extremis a
versatile technology that first showed
up in the Iron Man comics and is
reimagined here as a way to superheat
one's body and literally regrow limbs
Killian's particular skill set makes for
one of the most technically ambitious
fight scenes in the m you and sometimes
hard to believe any villain can truly go
toe-to-toe with Tony Stark but Killian
made a heck of a run
Peter Quill's search for his father was
a key part of Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 2 a journey that brought him face to
face with Kurt Russell's ego who's as
bad a dad as a comp ego is one of the
most powerful villains in the MCU right
up there alongside Thanos himself he
goes essentially a God who wants to
literally become the universe by
replacing all other life and Russell
sells it so well that you really
understand where ego's coming from even
if he's a psychopath who's killed
hundreds of his own children in his
quest for power ego redefined the
concept of daddy issues of course I have
issues
father Mysterio isn't the best villain
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe but it
might just be the cleverest after 10
years of movies inspired by Comics the
MCU proofed with endgame that it was its
own distinct version of the superhero
Universe a series of alternate surprises
led to Mysterio with a promise of a
Multiverse that could take thanks to the
next level and then we find out that
it's all just one big con instead of
being the way forward Mysterio ties
everything back to the very first Iron
Man movie and is one of the many things
that made far from home the perfect
epilogue to the infinity Saga in a
universe of world destroying monsters
the vulture is decidedly street level in
his approach but that's exactly what
makes him work the film's writers
tweaked his backstory to make Adrian
tombs the father of Peter Parker's
teenage crush and Spider-Man homecoming
and he takes the girlfriend's Angry Dad
Trope to a whole new level the effects
team did an amazing job with his armor
in appearance with the vulture looking
positively terrifying and inhuman when
he's stalking his prey we've never seen
Thor face a Villain Like hella the
goddess of death and any of the other
MCU films much like Loki before her this
has Guardian villain as someone
audiences will immediately love to hate
as soon as Odin passes away hella
appears to the brothers and presents her
plan to take her rightful place on
asgard's Throne to prove her Point she
easily crushes Thor's hammer the truth
is eventually revealed that hella once
acted as Odin's executioner leading the
Asgardian Army to victory over all nine
Realms this secret history elevates
hella to Epic villain status Eric
killmonger essentially has a superhero's
origin his father is killed in front of
him his Royal Heritage is denied to him
and he uses those tragedies to motivate
a Relentless dedication training himself
to the peak of his abilities before
seeking Vengeance that setup is a whole
lot closer to Batman than it is to
Ultron when you add in the fact that
killmonger specifically wants to address
a continuing history of racism it's hard
not to admit that he makes some pretty
good points even if he's right though
his goal is dominance rather than
leadership which makes him a true
ideological opponent for t'challa it's
one of the things that makes their final
battle in which they're both in nearly
identical black panther costumes so good
their reflections of each other both
committed to fight for their ideals
without compromising who they are
there's a reason Marvel Studios chose to
use Loki as an ongoing villain for The
Avengers he's one of the most compelling
calculated and charismatic villains ever
Tom Hiddleston is so good at being bad
that Marvel opted to keep him around
long after his bid for Supremacy was
foiled at the hands of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes he's still no match for the Hulk
but who is oh wait we know who Thanos is
the villain of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe there's been a lot of character
work put into the Cinematic version of
Thanos which is especially impressive
considering that most of it is shown to
the audience in Infinity War a movie
that's also juggling story arcs for
dozens of other characters at the same
time through it all he's shown to have
the same quality that all the greatest
villains share he thinks he's right he's
the hero of his own story the only one
who can step up and save the universe
from itself and is willing to sacrifice
whatever he needs to in pursuit of that
goal in the comics Thanos has been
referred to as the ultimate nihilist but
the mcu's version is the exact opposite
he believes very much in what he's doing
which makes him even more compelling and
more dangerous
once you've had a villain who can kill
half the universe with a snap of his
fingers what chance does any other
villain have of being that scary or
threatening let's take a look at some
villains from Marvel Comics who can give
Thanos a run for his money when it comes
to being frightening
Galactus isn't necessarily evil but he's
definitely terrifying he's an
Unstoppable force of Nature and while he
doesn't actually want to hurt any of the
trillions of people whose lives he's
ended over the years that's not because
he has any affection for them it's
because he just doesn't care about them
at all
great hunger is upon me all creatures
are enemies Galactus first arrived in
Fantastic Four number 48 by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby kicking off Decades of his
status as the definitive Cosmic threat
in Marvel Comics he's a survivor of the
universe before ours reborn in the Big
Bang as the Devourer of Worlds a
creature seemingly Beyond morality who
is driven by his endless hunger to eat
entire planets while he's been defeated
every time he's come to Earth in the
past including once when he was
confronted with the souls of every
living creature he devoured in his
billion year life his very existence is
downright lovecraftian for all its
colorful superheroes the Marvel Universe
also features a galactic Force to whom
all of humanity is completely
insignificant and who might show up to
end life on Earth whenever he gets
peckish
when annihilus was first introduced in
the pages of Fantastic Four he was
called The Living death that walks and
in the years since he's more than lived
up to that title Thanos might have
killed half the universe and Galactus
might devour planets but they at least
see what they're doing as necessary
annihilus on the other hand doesn't just
pillage his way across the Galaxy he
enjoys every second of it at heart
annihilus is an insect and as the ruler
of the chaotic interdimensional Negative
Zone he's got an entire swarm of space
Locus at his command ready to consume
everything in their path that's exactly
what happened in Marvel's Annihilation
crossover where he led an insectoid
armada to destroy entire planets he's
incapable of pity or remorse and would
casually snuff out billions of lives
just to expand his Empire
the Marvel universe is full of
unsettling monstrosities and compared to
them an overgrown octopus with a
gigantic eye might not seem that scary
the thing is that's not really Shuma
garath it's just the way it appears in
the physical world in reality well it's
reality anyway it's part of an extra
dimensional race of beings known as the
many angled ones who ruled Earth as Gods
during prehistory it was cast down by
krom the uncaring warrior God worshiped
by Conan the Barbarian but it's been
trying to find its way back to Earth
ever since I will come for your
dimension next as Marvel's attempt to
bring some HP Lovecraft style horror to
the comics page Shuma gorath was
terrifying from its very first
appearance when it forced Doctor Strange
to kill his own teacher in order to stop
the evil possessing him from within
there have been evil gods in the Marvel
Universe for as long as Loki's been
around but Shuma gorath was the first
one to be in human and incomprehensible
which makes it way scarier
as a creature who exists entirely on the
astral plane in the realm of thoughts
the Shadow King has no body of his own
he can however take over anyone else's
body and consume their personality when
that happens we're not just talking
about the kind of mind control that's
common in superhero Stories the Shadow
King wants to experience the physical
world however he can spending years in a
body using it to live out his every
hedonistic desire and ruining the body
in the process one of the most
horrifying examples of his parasitic use
of his host comes in the pages of New
Mutants when he took over Karma and
twisted her body into something
monstrous from an Indulgence in carnal
Pleasures more recently he's been used
as the primary villain on the TV series
Legion which depicts him as the
chameleon-like creature of corruption
that he's always been in the comics
kilgrave also known as the purple man
isn't a God or a cosmic entity or a
non-corporeal psychic being he's just a
man with one of the most simple
superpowers imaginable he can make
anyone do anything he wants his
slightest suggestion is an irresistible
command if he tells someone to stop
breathing they'll suffocate without
drawing another breath he can't even
turn his power on and off when he was
first created he was just another
mind-controlling super villain but over
the years his ability to effortlessly
control everyone around him twisted his
mind into something truly horrifying
when he was brought back to Comics as
part of Jessica Jones's backstory his
true terrifying potential was on display
with his ability to Rob victims of their
own will and autonomy combined with the
very real world horror of sexual assault
Comics creators borrow ideas from other
pieces of Pop Culture all the time and
The Brood might be one of the best
examples created in the pages of Uncanny
X-Men in 1982 they're pretty much just
the Marvel Universe equivalent of the
creature from Ridley Scott's 1979 film
Alien in the interest of doing something
slightly different from that film though
Chris Claremont and Dave cockram created
an even more viscerally frightening body
Horror concept while the xenomorph from
alien implants an egg that bursts out of
a human body and kills the host The
Brood reproduce in another way their
eggs don't burst out they take over
their victims bodies and transform them
into new brood the host is still trapped
in there while their new form uses their
memories and knowledge to more
effectively conquer the Galaxy in other
words The Brood are the answer to the
question what if Xenomorphs were also
zombies and also trapped you in a
mutated body that you couldn't control
fear comes in many shapes and these guys
are at least three of them
we've seen countless King villains some
are utterly horrifying and others are
completely laughable but there's a
handful that are so terrifying they'll
Inspire nightmares these are the Stephen
King movie villains who've kept us up at
night ranked from worst to the very best
the Shawshank Redemption demonstrates
how some of the scariest movie monsters
are the ones you could meet in real life
Warden Samuel Norton is a man who's
willing to do whatever it takes to gain
power over others
don't you ever mention money to me again
he claims to be a man of God but he runs
Shawshank State Prison like a slave
owner manipulating inmates to do his
bidding and punishing anyone who doesn't
comply ultimately Norton is a coward he
chooses to take the easy way out when
confronted with his own misdeeds but
cowards like Norton are capable of doing
some truly frightening and Despicable
things and they shouldn't be
underestimated we can't say for certain
whether Stephen King has something
against organized religion but religious
figures are often the villains in his
story take Reverend Lowe for example a
man of the cloth with a beastly secret
1985 Silver Bullet tells the story of a
small town terrorized by a werewolf and
the people who are brave enough to fight
the ungodly creature the film is
indicative of a lot of horror films that
came out in the 1980s it's more cheesy
than actually scary honestly the fact
that Gary Busey is one of the Stars
tells you everything you need to know
still werewolves are scary beasts and
the fact that this werewolf is the
town's religious leader makes him all
the more frightening there's nothing
scarier than an evil child and the town
and Children of the Corn is full of them
some might argue that the scariest
presence in the film is He Who Walks
Behind The Rose that's the fertility
demon who dwells in the cornfield and
these nasty kids keep sacrificing the
town's adults in order to appease him of
course demons are bad news on the best
of days but there's something about a
charismatic cult leader a child in this
case that strikes us as even more
horrifying in the dream
the law did come to me and he was a
shape it was He Who Walks Behind The
Rose
actor John Franklin does an incredible
job portraying a corrupt power mad
adolescent thanks to his performance the
film becomes less about the horror of a
cornfield demon and more about the
dangers of charismatic Leaders with
frightening ulterior motives
beep beep what's worse than buying a new
car only to find out it's pure evil uh
nothing actually Christine is a unique
horror film that takes something as
mundane as a car and turns it into an
Unstoppable killing machine Christine
isn't one of the most popular King
adaptations but it's still a pretty
intense Thrill Ride and the film is
certainly worth giving a whirl
okay
show me
while it's obviously impossible for an
inanimate object to convey emotion
director John Carpenter and his star
Keith Gordon are great at making it seem
like Christine has a personality all her
own however terrifying that personality
may be fun fact the film's famous
Resurrection scene almost didn't happen
on screen Carpenter added it after
production wrapped because he felt the
movie needed more special effects
Stephen King is an absolute Master when
it comes to Turning life's everyday
Comforts into total nightmares Cujo
tells the story of Donna and Tad a
mother and son who are forced into a hot
broken down car by a rabid Saint Bernard
that's quite literally foaming at the
mouth the film turns out to be less
about a killer dog and more about human
relationships and childhood trauma and
Cujo comes to represent all the terrible
things that are happening in Donna's
family also what's more frightening than
watching a lovable creature turn into a
bloodthirsty monster and through no
fault of his own at the beginning of the
film cucho is a sweet curious dog who
simply winds up in the wrong place at
the wrong time oh and speaking of being
in the wrong place at the wrong time
foreign
the audience feels a real sense of
helplessness as they watch the creature
transform before their eyes and that
sense of helplessness soon turns to
utter horror mothers can be monstrous in
real life and in the movies and as far
as Bad Mamas go you'd be hard-pressed to
find a mother as depraved and dangerous
as Carrie's Margaret White she's a
religious zealot who feels an
overwhelming compulsion to punish her
daughter Carrie at every turn calling
her a sinner whenever she gets the
chance she's also fond of locking poor
Carrie in a prayer closet essentially a
broom closet adorned with candles and
religious icons including the creepiest
crucifix you've ever seen when Carrie
gets her first period Margaret tells her
it's because she's had impure thoughts
oh Lord hell the Sydney woman see the
sin of our days and ways at the end of
the day she's an all-around miserable
person who thinks sex and sexuality is
sinful and revolting of course Margaret
gets hers in the end because having a
telekinetic daughter who throws knives
with her mind isn't without its risks
but while she's alive man Margaret is a
friggin nightmare Kurt Barlow from
Salem's Lot is the quintessential
Boogeyman the vampire is barely seen
throughout the two-part miniseries which
had a theatrical release in Europe
preferring to prey on the people of
Salem's Lot under a veil of darkness and
Chic Mystique but when he finally does
show his face he's a decidedly unsexy
vampire there's no mistaking him for
Edward Cullen
I'm going to kill you
Barlow is more akin to nosferatu's
Central creep another repulsive monster
who doesn't waste time trying to charm
his victims Barlow keeps his eye on the
prize and just focuses on what he does
best terrorizing the town's people
[Applause]
hey look at him
[Music]
when he was alive pet cemeteries Gage
Creed was a real cute little kid but
after a fatal accident involving an
18-wheeler his father made the perfect
worst choice and decided to go ahead and
reanimate him the result of all this
inadvisable Hocus Pocus is not so cute
I'm glad to something Mommy
okay maybe he's still pretty cute
nevertheless he turns into a murderous
zombie with a fondness for scalpels he
sneaks he creeps you'll always find him
in the most unexpected places basically
he's a full-fledged Menace who must be
stopped in the end Gage's odd mixture of
childlike innocence and Unstoppable evil
adds up to Pure unadulterated nightmare
fuel as a wise man once said sometimes
dad is better
Gage is the embodiment of corrupted
innocence a victim of unfortunate
circumstances his transformation into a
tiny monster is ultimately the byproduct
of his father's grief in that regard pet
cemetery is a terribly sad film on top
of being absolutely terrifying let's
face it most insects and arachnids are
pretty off-putting in real life the mere
sight of a creepy crawly is a Surefire
way to get the blood pumping a fact that
horror directors are all too happy to
exploit well the creatures in the Mist
are all supersized and so is your
mounting sense of dread just take a look
at this angry militia of creepos if you
don't believe us most of the action in
the Mist takes place in a single
location a store that suddenly become
enveloped in a thick mysterious fog most
of the people trapped inside are loathed
to venture out those who do explore the
Mist end up meeting horrible Fates the
Mist monsters are otherworldly creatures
that go sight unseen throughout much of
the film but when we finally do catch a
glimpse it's not a happy sight
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
those oversized tentacles are not for
the faint of heart and the sharp
Pinchers should give you a pause too
they're ghastly malevolent monsters and
it's really best to avoid them there's
certainly no reasoning with them just
try talking some sense into this guy
these monsters are seemingly Unstoppable
too the only way to save yourself from a
gruesome death is to fight back and
that's way easier said than done
looking for a life of Fame and Glory
while Annie Wilkes will make you think
twice about that misery tells the story
of Paul Sheldon a famous writer who's
taken in by a seemingly gregarious nurse
following a serious car accident Annie
is all too willing to help Paul get back
on his feet but she's also happy to
break his ankles after all she's his
number one fan and she feels things very
strongly I'm also a nurse
and in case you haven't caught on yet
she's also a total friggin psychopath
Wilkes holds the poor writer hostage
forcing him to rewrite his latest book
in a way that she deems satisfying and
appropriate no profanity no cheap
endings and when he tries to escape this
horrible predicament she hobbles him
with a sledgehammer all the while
assuring him that she's his biggest fan
Annie is easily one of Stephen King's
most frightening villains and part of
what makes her so terrifying is Kathy
Bates incredible performance she
rightfully earned an Oscar for her work
and it's easy to see why total film said
Annie Wilkes is one of Cinema's greatest
friendliest monsters indeed part of what
makes Annie so awful is the fact that
she really does love Paul but when
admiration turns into Obsession there's
no telling what a person is capable of
doing and Annie is apparently willing to
do anything no matter how wretched it is
the 1980 film adaptation of The Shining
is a Bonafide horror Masterpiece
director Stanley Kubrick created a
ghostly and ghastly world inside the
Overlook Hotel and is utterly terrifying
film is widely considered an essential
iconic piece of horror Cinema the story
revolves around a writer and family man
who loses his mind inside a haunted
hotel which sounds somewhat
straightforward at first but there's a
lot going on here though Kubrick's
vision is something of a departure from
Stephen King's original novel his take
on the haunted hotel has unspeakable
Horrors waiting behind every door and
just around every corner as The Story
Goes The Overlook Hotel was apparently
built on an Indian burial ground and any
horror fan knows that's never a good
sign throughout the film The formidable
building establishes itself as something
of a villain in its own right it really
feels like a living breathing entity
with blood on its mind the ghosts that
seem to inhabit the property are all
deranged and diabolical in one way or
another there are elevators full of
blood ballrooms teeming with ghost
specters and who the hell knows what's
going on in room 237
from the Grady twins to these two fine
fellows there's something to fear on
every floor of the Overlook Hotel he can
run but you can't hide
though the spectral Hotel guests at the
Overlook Hotel are admittedly creepy
it's questionable whether any of them
can physically harm you still there's no
doubt they'll drive you towards Madness
using every trick at their disposal case
in point Jack Torrance who totally loses
his mind throughout the course of the
film he starts out as a deeply
frustrated husband and father who seems
to have a rather short fuse but he
slowly transforms into a genuine monster
a monster who happens to be highly
proficient with an ax
here's Johnny
taking the job at the Overlook proves to
be Jack's undoing we watch helplessly as
he loses his grip on reality and
sometimes it feels like we're losing it
right along with him he becomes more and
more terrifying with every scene and
when he finally meets his demise there's
something truly awful in that Frozen
Grimace and the vision stays with us
long after the final frame of the film
of course that final frame is creepy in
its own right if you were a child in the
90s there's a good chance you caught the
it miniseries starring Tim Curry as the
child eating Pennywise the Dancing Clown
come on oh my God
why is
that Curry's Pennywise was a villain
that made kids afraid to turn off their
bedroom lights not just because clowns
are inherently awful but because this
clown can manifest as your greatest fear
it can also get to you quite easily
wherever you happen to be although the
it miniseries has arguably lost a bit of
its bite in recent years Pennywise the
Dancing Clown is still a force to be
reckoned with in the recent it films
Bill Skarsgard takes on the meaty role
and his interpretation is dazzlingly
demented in its own right the pancake
makeup the teeth that hideous dance
foreign
the new Pennywise is the perfect villain
for these troubling times at the end of
the day we all get the monsters we
deserve
The Walking Dead has no shortage of bad
guys big and small but who's the biggest
baddest antagonist of them all we're
here to find out by ranking every single
major Walking Dead villain from the
least impressive to the most brutally
fearsome
first introduced in season 7 Jadis is
the leader of a faction known as the
Scavengers Rick approaches them in the
hopes of gaining more soldiers in his
fight against Negan and the saviors
jadus is depicted as a Kurt Cole leader
of a handful of loyal survivors she
lives in a junkyard where she often
makes art out of the items that are
discarded and chooses to speak in broken
English still
alone you
[Music]
lead us to save you although her
eccentricities make Jadis whose real
name is later revealed to be an
irritating they're not the reason she
ranks as one of the worst villains on
the show when push comes to shove
jadus's move is always to extort
something out of the people she has
power over when Rick comes with his hat
in his hand she demands some kind of
tribute when she agrees to fight
alongside him she eventually betrays the
alexandrians and joins the saviors only
to later betray them when the tide of
the battle shifts
in the end she makes one greedy choice
too many and her entire group is
massacred by the saviors at the behest
of Simon her time as a villain is marked
by perplexing character traits and an
inability to really impact the outcome
of the world
when Gregory is introduced he seems like
an impressive figure he's run the
hilltop Colony since the beginning and
by season 6 it stands as one of the few
safe havens left in the world however as
the world grows an alliances start to
form it becomes clear that Gregory is
only a peacetime leader and a very
average one at that when the saviors
first arrived he's unable to put up much
of a fight and almost immediately rolls
over once Rick comes around he realizes
that his people need some muscle and
agrees to help right up until Rick loses
his first battle with the saviors he
then declares their deal null and void
after that Maggie gains popularity as a
leader among Hilltop residents prompting
Gregory to attempt to defect to the
saviors perhaps you've already noticed
the pattern here Gregory gives up at the
drop of a hat whenever things get real
he simply quits and joins the other team
bouncing back and forth between the good
guys and bad guys and having little
impact on either faction you're really
gonna stand there and pretend you didn't
try to sell us out sell this place out
to the saviors I was working for the
side of Sanity I was working for peace
hero or villain a person in the world of
The Walking Dead has to make big moves
that might lead to conflict even if he's
no fighter maintaining control is key
and Gregory from the get-go never really
has control of anyone or anything
it's rare that a villainous group on The
Walking Dead has no distinct leader but
such is the case with the Wolves the
wolves are a group of marauders active
in the Washington DC area who Survive by
raiding any living people for supplies
then using their zombified bodies as
bait to attract more prey they Foster a
sense of unease in the area by marking
areas they've hit with the words wolves
not far yet theatrics don't end there
they carve a w into both their foreheads
and the foreheads of their victims for
all their style the Wolves don't last
very long against Rick's group or even
Carol on her own in season 6 after
teasing their presence in the area for
weeks they launch a full-on attack on
Alexandria in the end however their
attack on Alexandria is nothing more
than a surprisingly toothless display of
intimidation Carol disguised as a wolf
successfully Slaughters a number of them
and the alexandrians are able to repel
their forces so much for the Wolves
ferocity you said it right
don't ever be sorry
All Things Considered Gareth is actually
a pretty Savvy villain not only does he
lead a large faction of people he
manages to hatch a pretty clever scheme
that brings a lot of unsuspecting
victims into his web after founding
Terminus as a safe haven gareth's good
intentions are foiled by a group of
hostile survivors who briefly take over
he manages to get the place back but
only by resorting to villainous tactics
following this Gareth grows merciless
and turns his little Beacon of Hope into
a trap for people in the area who hear
radio broadcast ailing Terminus as a
sanctuary in reality it's a meat factory
for cannibals it makes you feel any
better
you taste much better than we thought
you would
the only reason Gareth ranked so low on
this list is simply that his villainy
doesn't last long in the face of Rick
Grimes and his survivors after Gareth
captures the group and attempts to
slaughter them for meat Rick and Company
managed to escape and take Terminus out
with everything he built in Ruins Gareth
tracks them to a nearby church and
manages to capture Bob ultimately though
his tracking amounts to nothing as Rick
makes good on his promise to kill him
with a red-handled machete Gareth is
neither the most cunning nor the most
threatening villain on The Walking Dead
but he does manage to build something
worthy of infamy unfortunately his
contribution to the world ends there
the white is an enormously complicated
villain however that complexity somewhat
diminishes his level of success as a bad
guy his heart just isn't in it Dwight is
introduced as someone who betrays
Daryl's kindness on the road after
fleeing the saviors with his wife and
sister-in-law eventually the family
returns and Negan separates the wife
from his wife and burns half his face
off with anion for his desertion after
enduring this trauma and spending a good
portion of time in solitary confinement
Dwight emerges as one of negan's top
guys he's reintroduced to the survivors
after he mercilessly shoots Denise
through the eye and is part of the team
that captures the survivors before
Abraham and Glenn are executed by Negan
basically Dwight is an irredeemable
bastard at this point in the story
however his love for his wife keeps a
singular spark of humanity alive within
him and eventually he makes the Bold
choice to turn on Negan and the saviors
and act as a mole for the alexandrians
I hate them
I hate naked
for a Time Dwight is a pretty
captivating figure to watch because it's
genuinely unclear where his loyalties
lie in the end he makes the tough call
to do the right thing and Daryl spares
his life as a result he's one of the
Walking Dead's more understated
antagonist and that makes him a
relatively minor figure on this list but
definitely not in the hearts of the
show's fans
while Jill never leads a large group
like Jadis Gareth or the Wolves he gets
major points for being a seriously evil
person he's first introduced as the
leader of a very small group of
marauders called the claimers they roll
into a house that Rick happens to be
hiding out in and quickly demonstrate
their depravity Rick manages to escape
them but not without killing a claimer
while tracking Rick down for Revenge Joe
meets and befriends Daryl and explains
his philosophy on leadership Joe manages
to keep his small group in line by
issuing one major rule anyone who claims
something owns it by right those who
violate this rule are punished with a
beating or Worse the claimers are a
small faction because Joe deals with
internal conflicts by straight up
killing the person who is at fault when
Joe catches up to Rick he threatens to
kill Daryl and assault both Michonne and
Carl he genuinely gets one over on Rick
but only briefly because Joe
underestimates his opponent's savagery
Rick rips out Joe's throat with his
teeth putting it into his misguided
worldview right then and there the whole
part I never looked at like that seems
to me like things are only starting to
fall together
at least for guys like us
sometimes the scariest villains are the
ones who are convinced they're the good
guy when Dawn is introduced she's
several years into the apocalypse but is
still holding out hope for a government
Rescue Dawn presides over a hospital
that she and a handful of other
survivors cops and Physicians have
turned into a very tense Safe Haven with
resources dwindling Dawn allows all
sorts of horrific crimes all in the name
of keeping their way of life going until
a government rescue arrives this is as
the audience knows a long wait for a
train that simply isn't coming try to
look at the good we're doing
hard as it was we saved Jones life
Trevor's life we saved your life
when Beth arrives as a patient she's
given a crash course in Dawn's deeply
and profoundly misguided way of leading
when Beth befriends a guy named Noah
they hatch a plan that half fails and
only allows him to escape while Beth
stays back and faces the consequences
from one of Dawn's men it becomes clear
that Dawn is losing control prompting
her to do something drastic when best
group comes to negotiate a trade for
Beth and Carol who has been injured and
brought to the hospital Don tries to
prove herself by demanding they get Noah
back as well driven to Madness by her
brief time with Dawn Beth stabs her Don
reflexively shoots her and is
immediately shot dead by Daryl
the governor AKA Philip Blake deserves
High honors for being the Walking Dead's
very first through and through
honest-to-god villain prior to his
arrival the worst threat to humanity is
Merle Dixon when Daryl's brother is
finally seen again after more than a
year he's following the governor's
orders which really says something about
the company Blake keeps when the
governor is introduced he is revealed to
have accomplished what Rick has failed
to do he has created a working Society
within the zombie apocalypse while the
show has since seen a bevy of
strongholds from both good guys and bad
guys take shape the governor is the
first to do it it's not exactly a
success however things get very
dystopian there only about a year or two
out from the onset of the Apocalypse you
know all about me and I know all about
you I don't care about any of that we're
here to move forward
what really makes the governor a top
villain isn't his leadership but his
Madness there's just no telling how
he'll wields his power from moment to
moment even his demise comes as a result
of his own lunacy upset over the loss of
Woodbury and its people's assimilation
into the prison he drives a tank through
one of the only safe havens left in the
world and dies trying to exact physical
revenge on Rick Grimes
Alpha is Kurt cold and has no time for
any weakness in her ranks she survives
by Leading a group called The Whisperers
who live among the Walkers and even
manage to control their movements
through herding tactics she is the first
to recognize that the Walkers are the
weapon that brought Humanity to its
knees making even the mightiest people
and institutions fall so when she
encounters Rick's group she has very
little time for their emotionality and
moral compunctions however since they've
captured her only daughter Lydia she has
no choice but to roll through them with
brutal Vengeance the war with the
whisperers becomes one of the strongest
conflicts in the series though beta
Alpha's right-hand man does most of the
heavy lifting she's the one who herds
enough Walkers to basically wield this
world's equivalent of a noob Alpha is
one of very few villains on The Walking
Dead who doesn't underestimate her
opponents and that counts for everything
could I make him strong
even people with a cursory understanding
of The Walking Dead know that Negan is
the greatest antagonist the show has
ever seen although he spends a majority
of his time on the show on a path to
Redemption he wouldn't even be alive if
it wasn't for his ruthlessness when
Negan is first introduced he infamously
kills Abraham and Glenn for no other
reason than to demonstrate his power
Negan has a twisted way of always making
good decisions he views people as a
resource this means he's not a loose
cannon homicidal maniac like the
governor or Joe his conflicts are
calculated and he knows who will live or
die before he even begins a conversation
when it comes to leadership he defers
from Jadis and Dawn in that he knows
success lies not in keeping people going
but in giving them an opportunity to
thrive hence the sanctuary's point
system let Mark's face be a daily
reminder to him and everyone else that
the rules matter however the main thing
that makes Negan such an effective
villain is the fact that he's capable
unlike Gregory or Dodd when push comes
to shove Negan can fend for himself he
boasts the smartest and most broken mind
in any room and is enormously capable of
exerting his will on the people around
him
from track suits that have seen better
days to Slick vinyl catsuits we're here
to investigate what DC's bad guys
actually look like in the comics they
still call home and just how different
that is from what makes it onto the
Silver Screen
The Joker has a pretty packed wardrobe
Batman t-shirts he's sporting them in
Sean Murphy's miniseries Batman White
Knight sleeveless doctor's coat Joker
donned one in Batman R.I.P still over
the decades a central look emerges
Classic Suits and tuxedos and green
orange purple and red he first appeared
in a large bow tie purple gloves and
well pomated hair though artists often
add a couple of unhinged details to his
look most often must-hair are outsized
teeth The Joker tends to keep himself as
well turned out as a Downton Abbey
character modern movie audiences have
three very different Jokers to consider
Heath Ledger's clown is a mangy
monstrosity whose makeup visually flakes
off throughout the movie Joaquin
Phoenix's take on the character looks to
famous mid-century television clowns
like Bozo and howdy Duty's Clarabelle
for inspiration Jared Leto's demonic
Wild Child swaps formal wear for face
tattoos and lyric purple coats over a
bare chest each of these interpretations
tells the audience something different
Leto's Joker is more of a mafioso than a
mastermind Phoenix's Joker is a 1970s
every man gone off the deep end and
Ledger's Joker is a nightmarish vision
of Urban Decay but not one of them is as
sharply dressed as The Madman of the
monthlies some of those movie guys are
just a mess do I really look like a guy
with a plan Doomsday's appeal is pretty
much summed up by his name he is the
Reckoning at the end of Superman's
Adventures appropriately he is best
known as the villain of the death of
Superman the result of alien scientist
krypton's genetic engineering doomsday
is a Greg Goliath whose skeleton spikes
through his skin Doomsday's incarnation
in Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
was a very different creature indeed the
product of Lex Luthor is meddling with
General zod's corpse this doomsday was
as large and gray as his comic
counterpart but not quite as hard edged
those spikes of bone emerged mid-battle
from his skin he starts out as a
deformed gray brute moreover this
doomsday developed the ability to shoot
blasts of energy out of his hands after
absorbing the energy from a nuclear
strike the Doomsday of the comics only
develops this ability after his faithful
battle with the outsider's super team
doomsday on film is a grunting Primal
version of brutality something like the
distant ancestor of the comics version
the feline Fatale likes to keep it Sleek
the Catwoman of the 1966 Batman TV
series accentuated basic black with
glittering accessories and a striking
mask Batman Returns imagined Catwoman is
a city girl pushed to Madness symbolized
by her visibly stitched Patchwork of the
catsuit Halle Berry's costume was
shredded but still as dark as the
Shadows The Dark Knight Rises depicted
Catwoman as a burglar and matte black
with pointed stilettos and Cat eared
tips on her goggles these incarnate
though impressive in their cinematic
Vision rely on small details to do the
heavy lifting of her characterization
but the Catwoman of comics has a more
varied wardrobe ranging from Emerald
evening wear to Royal Purple catsuits
for all that trail of the Catwoman
artist Darwin Cooks 2001 redesign was so
immediately iconic in it Catwoman wears
a simple catsuit and a cat-eared cowl
set off by flat-footed motorcycle boots
and flared goggles it's simple and
remarkably practical but its Sleek
details make it Timeless Catwoman's
taste might run to the extravagant but
when she's on the job she keeps things
functional
what are we gonna do
there's not much we can do
that's who I think it is
being the literal God of War requires an
impressive outfit Aries does just that
in the 2017 Wonder Woman film with
Shining Armor spiked helmet and enormous
Weaponry War sure ain't subtle Aries of
the comics follow suit and George
Perez's classic tale on Wonder Woman and
Greg Ruka and Nicholas Scott's recent
Revival he wears dark blue armor a
plumed helmet and a billowing Cape it's
largely the same design as what ended up
on screen aside from one important
difference in the early Comics Ares has
no discernible body every inch of flash
is covered save a narrow Gap in his
helmet on any normal human this would
reveal a portion of the nose lips and
Chin on the comic character however
there is only depthless Darkness studded
with two smoldering eyes was it cool to
see the man who played Mild Manor Remus
Lupine glowering beneath the helmet yes
but it would have been equally striking
to see his face disappear after doing
away with this disguise
remember when the villain of Suicide
Squad opened an apocalyptic portal
through the art of aggressive belly
dancing and enchantress's defense when
you're a millennia spanning
interdimensional witch goddess you can
pretty much make your own rules that
certainly applied to the character's
wardrobe which shifted from rags and
tarnish jewelry to a billowing two-piece
Affair crowned by a roon inlaid
headdress was it an outfit made for
serious battle no way but enchantress's
Powers allow her to do other things
please don't touch me please don't touch
me introduced in a 1966 issue of strange
Adventures as the switcheroo witcheroo
the enchantress has cycled through many
outfits but all of them are in her
signature bright green and most feature
a flamboyant cloak perhaps her most
unique costume is her very first a
classic witch hat paired with a
harlequin patterned mini dress not great
for Suicide Squad but perfect for The
Swinging 60s Dr poison is one of Wonder
Woman's earliest villains and one of her
most terrifying a princess working as
the head of the Nazis poisoned Vision
she disguises her gender under her green
docker's gear and a mask with a rictus
grin her greatest creation was reverso a
poison that would force Allied soldiers
into doing the opposite of what they
were told Dr poison isn't a princess and
disguise as a man or working with Nazis
in 2017's Wonder Woman but she is just
as deadly and an intriguing twist Dr
Poison's mask was reimagined as a series
of flesh-colored plates affixed to her
face to hide the scars exposure to her
own Creations rot those plates aren't
just striking but rooted in actual
history soldiers disfigured in World War
1 brought about new Innovations in
prosthesis Dr poison might not have been
the leering Specter of the ax as she
began as but she filled Wonder Woman
audiences with a comparable sense of
Terror DC's New Gods exceeded
conventional Notions of superheroes
they've got fabulous Powers extravagant
outfits and wheeled technology capable
of transporting them across Dimensions
Steppenwolf is a new God and His
incarnation in the Justice League lived
up to that races Larger than Life
reputation he was a CGI Colossus of
armor Stone and steel beneath this
costume he was oddly waxed in an
appearance his skin had drained gray
crisscrossed by alien grooves add in two
bony outgrowths off his chin and you had
a truly fearsome looking opponent
[Music]
the Steppenwolf of modern Comics is
similarly Grand but he didn't start out
that way he first appears in the new
Gods series Sporting Green medieval
armor complete with a bike hocket hat
that makes him look more Robin Hood than
new God but in modern Renditions his
armor is red and black accented by a
skull worn at his waist and red
claw-like stripes atop his shoulders in
sharp contrast to the Steppenwolf of the
movies however his comic Incarnation is
notably handsome he wears a dark beard
sometimes Twisted into long braids movie
Steppenwolf is utterly unknowable while
comic Steppenwolf is a man who dressed
differently could pass for a hero as a
kid whose Powers allow him to transform
into a buff super heroic adult in a
flashy red suit Shazam embodies one of
the most potent fantasies in all of
comics appropriately his archenemy Dr
Savannah is boldly drawn Dr Savannah a
criminal mastermind whose love of
depraved science is matched only by his
ego give me your power
or die his appearance in Shazam isn't
too terribly far off the mark As in the
comics he is portrayed as a bald
smirking man who oozes ill intentions
but unlike the villain Mark Strong
portrayed on screen the doctor Savannah
of the comics is a hunched little man
with an oversized head his thick glasses
obscure his eyes which paired with the
old school lab coating favors create
nothing so much as the very image of the
mad scientist add in the Diabolical
alien worm Mr mind he is often seen with
and it all results in a man you'd give a
wide birth to on the street Roz al Ghul
didn't become the head of the League of
Assassins through subtlety he clawed his
way to power over the course of
centuries infiltrated the halls of the
wealthy and connected through genius and
determination and sired Talia al Ghul
herself one of Batman's most formidable
foes accordingly he cuts a fine figure
Roz adorns his roguish good looks with
emerald green caves bordered in Gold
intricately wrought jewelry and often a
lush length of fur Liam Neeson's
portrayal in Batman Begins is a dramatic
departure from this Rich refinement
there Roz Blends into the Shadows
through muted suits and dark training
gear he is last the distant master of a
thousand deadly hands and more the hands
themselves seeking to add Bruce Wayne to
his ranks through subterfuge you haven't
beaten me you've sacrifice sure-footing
for a killing stroke
though his subdued aesthetic is indeed
appropriate to that approach one can't
help but miss the flamboyance of his
comic Incarnation the man who had become
Ocean Master was born to power he's the
type of guy who likes to refer to his
Trident as a scepter and dresses
accordingly orm wears purple Scaled
Armor a finned helmet that covers his
eyes with black red Oblongs and a cape
even underwater ocean Masters final
costume in Aquaman is actually pretty
darn close to what he wears in the
comics including the cape but that
resplendent outfit comes only at the end
of the film during the final Face-Off
and is preceded by a host of other
extravagant costumes he begins with dark
armor of considerably more bulk than the
Sleek looks favored by the other
denizens of Atlantis later he dons
another set of armor brought entirely of
gold topped off by a thinned Crown arms
costumes send one very clear message he
is to be obeyed and he wants everyone to
know it super villain gimmicks range
wildly in fearsomeness sometimes you get
the Joker essentially the embodiment of
chaos and sometimes well you get a guy
like Captain Boomerang no one is exactly
surprised to see a guy named Captain
Boomerang in a well-worn tracksuit and
pop collar trench coat and Suicide Squad
missing a few teeth and sporting some
facial scars he's a guy who Revels in
being weird and even a little
off-putting the kind of Oddball who fits
in right alongside Killer Croc and
Harley Quinn Captain Boomerang is just
as weird in the comics but with a good
deal more than Ash rather than a ratty
tracksuit he began as a man in a
boomerang pattern tunic Ascot and jaunty
blue garrison cap though recent
incarnations have favored a more toned
down look his looks remain well cut and
elegant and often still incorporate
Boomerang patterns in an ascot he might
be strange but he's gonna look good
doing it even when he's bothering his
teammates with his boorishness and
hijinks one can only imagine the horror
Captain Boomerang of the comics would
feel upon glimpsing his Motley film self
to say nothing of the latter's
preoccupation with unicorns
nothing transforms a good movie villain
into a great one like a killer wardrobe
a badass backstory and a compelling
argument these villains all had a pretty
good point even if we were too busy
hating them to realize it
we should say up front that we firmly
believe the Dark Knights Joker to be a
raving sociopath and an absolute Menace
to Society but hear us out it's
sometimes hard to argue with this
philosophy that human beings are not
meant to be confined within a structured
society and yes human beings find ways
to remind us of the delicate nature of
social contracts every day you see this
is how crazy Batman's made Gotham if you
want order in Gotham Batman must take
off his mask and turn himself in oh and
every day he doesn't people will die
Jokers fairy vs fairy experiment may
have failed to bring Gotham to its knees
but that doesn't mean he wasn't right
about a certain gothamite's nature yup
we're talking about D.A Harvey Dent
better known as Two-Face Joker tortured
the noble lawmen emotionally and
physically early in the film before
breaking dense psyche and turning him
loose on a coin flipping Killing Spree
bringing Gotham's Golden Boy down into
the trenches with the rest of the city's
criminals was Joker's Masterpiece it was
only tarnished by Batman and chief
Gordon spinning the biggest Web of Lies
that Gotham has ever seen which sort of
feels like a loss for the supposed good
guys
count yourself lucky if you are not the
leader of the Free World when the
apocalypse begins that's just where Carl
Anheuser found himself when the end
began in the brainless disaster flick
2012. just exactly how long are these
things expecting Hold Us in place
Captain they're just meant to withstand
the first impact of the Waves Mr
Anheuser well Anheuser was an
antagonistic Pres
full-on villain status until he thwarted
the heroic efforts of Jackson Curtis to
save his family by unceremoniously
slamming the door to Salvation in the
Curtis family's Collective faces it's a
brutal moment to be sure but it's
important to remember that if Anheuser
hadn't shut the doors the world-ending
flood outside might have found its way
in it would have killed all the would-be
survivors aboard the ark and that would
have meant the end of humanity so yeah
Anheuser could have been nicer about
everything but seriously he had to close
those doors
sure Daniel Craig plays an excellent
Bond but the success of 2012's box
office smashing Skyfall owes a lot to
Javier bardem's performance as scorned
secret agent turned vengeful cyber
terrorist Raul Silva well there's no
question that Silva falls on the batty
side of the spectrum he's also well a
human a terrible awful no-good human but
a human nonetheless
I win
what do you say to that
he's talented sure and he's hyper
intelligent but he's also tortured sound
familiar there are definite parallels
between Silva a former MI6 agent who was
abandoned to be tortured by the Chinese
and bond in fact it was Silva's
sympathetic backstory that attracted
Bardem to the part the actor told Fox
News here there is a broken person what
I like the most is there is a clear
motive we understand he is very human
and this is powerful I was attracted to
the villain because I thought he was a
nice guy I could see it in his eyes
we're not sure we agree with bardham but
we'll admit Silva's about a sympathetic
as Bond villains get and that's got to
count for something you see we are the
last two rats
we can either eat each other
glory to everyone else
he was one of the biggest action heroes
of the day but if Top Gun were real life
there's no way that Tom Cruise's Pete
Maverick Mitchell would be a popular guy
the antagonist of the 80s classic Val
Kilmer's Tom Iceman kozanski on the
other hand very well might be as top dog
at the Naval Air Station Miramar Top Gun
school he spent years training to be the
best young pilot around so of course
he's going to have a problem with this
upstart Maverick turns up and displays a
blatant disregard for everyone's safety
you guys really are Cowboys what's your
problem kazansky
you're everyone's problem
that's because every time you go up in
the air you're unsafe at one stage
reports emerged suggesting that Crews
and Kilmer's onset relationship mirrored
that of their characters but if there
was ever any truth to this then it's
clearly all water under the bridge as
the pair are reuniting for Top Gun too
Kilmer was sidelined with throat cancer
for a while but he has revealed that
he's fit and well enough to reprise the
role of Iceman in the upcoming sequel I
don't like you because you're dangerous
that's right
man
I am dangerous
everyone loves a good villain and
Disney's baddies are among the most
beloved and feared in all of Cinema but
while they're hideous skulls and evil
plans are more than enough to scare the
kids there are a few aspects to these
villains that only adults will pick up
on
it's hard to forget Ursula the big bad
of 1989's The Little Mermaid with her
particularly deceitful scheme her eel
henchmen and her instantly iconic music
number Poor Unfortunate Souls Ursula has
easily become one of the most distinct
members of the Disney villain Canon but
something else sets Ursula apart from
her fellow Disney baddies and that's her
real life inspiration of all people
Ursula had her design based on the
famous drag queen and actor Divine so
just how did the star of raunchy John
Waters movies like pink flamingos and
multiple Maniacs come to inspire the
villain of a G-rated Disney musical well
animator Rob Minkoff Drew up a design of
Ursula that ended up bearing a strong
resemblance to Divine Little Mermaid
composer Howard Ashman a major fan of
both John Waters and divine strongly
endorse the design Choice Disney's other
animators took further visual influence
from Divine by giving Ursula a hairstyle
similar to the one done by the drag
queen in Pink Flamingos the connection
between the two only grew as Ashman
committed to channeling divine's Uber
confident Persona into Ursula's
performance during Poor Unfortunate
Souls
The Hunchback of Notre Dame broke down
many barriers in the world of Disney
animation for one thing this 1996
adaptation of Victor Hugo's novel
explicitly tackled the subject of
religion which no other film in the
Studio's Canon has done for another it
gave a truly adult motivation to its
antagonist Claude frollo as in Hugo's
original novel frollo is a studious
Justice Minister who frowns upon
anything sexual in nature however the
character of Esmeralda a person frollo
publicly refers to as disgusting filth
stirs up feelings of passion inside
frollo's hard his internal conflict over
these forbidden emotions becomes so
great that his villain musical number
Hellfire is fixated on him begging for
forgiveness from God for feeling such
intense lust where other Disney villains
are motivated by greed or Revenge
frollo's crisis is dictated entirely by
his sexuality this is unexpectedly bold
storytelling territory from Disney a
studio that spent the 1990s releasing
more explicit Kitty Fair like this
[Music]
earthwormy goodness
indeed upon its initial release the Los
Angeles Times reported letters from
parents questioning the movie's darker
material including frollo's internal
conflict were too adult for a kids movie
nonetheless by daring to give its
villains such a complex and mature
motivation The Hunchback of Notre Dame
was able to solidify itself as one of
the more unique and underrated Disney
animations
over the years everyone from Claude
Reigns to Oscar Isaac has portrayed
Robin Hood's greedy Nemesis Prince John
so when it was time for Disney to take
on the story of Robin Hood it was
inevitable that the filmmakers were
going to create their own unique version
of the character and in Disney's 1973
animated classic John is portrayed as a
cowardly thumb sucking lion voiced by
two-time Academy Award winner Peter
eustanov Disney's Prince John quickly
became one of the most iconic versions
of the character and for obvious reasons
one of the silliest and most cartoonish
too so much so in fact that it can be
easy to forget that Prince John was in
fact a real historical figure long
before the release of Disney's film King
John ruled over England for 17 years
between 1199 and 1216. sadly there's
little historical evidence connecting
Jon and the semi-mythical figure of
Robin Hood in the real world however the
frequently antagonistic depiction of
John and pop culture stems from how he
has been commonly regarded as one of
England's worst kings as far as kings go
Jon didn't have a lot going for him he
lost critical lands in France sent
England into Financial ruin and most
famously of all was forced to sign the
Magna Carta after facing a Revolt from
his own Barons Jon quickly cultivated a
toxic reputation amongst contemporaries
one that survives to this day in stories
like Robin Hood so while children will
appreciate Disney's take on Prince John
as a particularly silly entry into the
pantheon of Disney villains the
grown-ups will be more than aware of the
real man who presented an equally real
danger to his own people
unlike most animated Disney movies
Pocahontas is actually based on a true
story however its deviations from
reality have inspired a decent amount of
criticism over the years including the
lack of evidence for there having been a
romantic relationship between John Smith
and Pocahontas and one of the more
significant changes in the movie's plot
can be found in the fate of its villain
John Ratcliffe and Disney's Pocahontas
Ratcliffe is depicted as a gold hungry
Captain who puts his own selfish
interests Above All Else including the
safety of the indigenous Americans and
with his love of money power and
flamboyant fashion sense Radcliffe fits
nicely alongside his fellow Disney
villains unlike most Disney villains
however Radcliffe is based on an actual
person the real Ratcliffe was an early
settler to America who eventually became
the second President of the Jamestown
Colony whereas Pocahontas depicts
Radcliffe being tied up and taken back
to England to pay for his crimes however
the actual Ratcliffe was killed by
powaton Indians of course Pocahontas has
a film more interested in using the
details of America's settlement as a
springboard for its own story rather
than adhering to the specific factual
details of the era and although it's
nice to see a little dash of reality in
a story like this it's probably best not
to go looking to Disney movies for a
historical accuracy
one of the most striking segments in the
1940 film Fantasia is entitled Night on
Bald Mountain set to the piece of music
of the same name the short depicts a
gigantic monstrous being Awakening an
assortment of spirits eventually the
spirits and the beasts are held at Bay
at the sound of the peeling bells and a
chorus of monks singing Ave Maria
though never given a name in Fantasia
itself the beast at the center of Night
on Bald Mountain is named chernabog
adult viewers well-versed in ancient
mythology will recognize chernabog's
name as one derived from the world of
Slavic myths specifically chernabog's
name means black God and he's also known
as the Lord of evil a creature whose
Deeds were too Wicked to be told in
classic mythology
interestingly another ancient being also
seems to have played a part in inspiring
chernabok in Fantasia the host deems
Taylor refers to chernabog as Satan Bald
Mountain according to tradition is the
Gathering Place of Satan and his
followers
though the character is officially named
chernobog design similarities between
Fantasia's chernabog and the traditional
depiction of Satan are apparent
particularly in their horned heads and
while Knight on Bald Mountain turned out
to be a distinctive enough Endeavor to
ensure that chernobog could stand on its
own two demonic feat grown-up viewers
should be able to appreciate the
terrifying nature of chernbog's true
Origins
some Disney villains yearn for world
domination some want revenge others are
motivated by prophecies dictated by
Magic mirrors Cruella Deville however is
one Disney villain who keeps her aims
much simpler all she wants is to take 99
Dalmatian puppies and turn them into a
fur coat and sure the scheme concocted
by 101 Dalmatians puppy fixated
antagonists aren't exactly ripped from
reality but the Disney version of author
Dodie Smith's legendary villain did take
cues from reality through real life
actress Tallulah Bankhead in a 1985
piece for the Los Angeles Times animator
Mark Davis revealed that Tallulah
Bankhead an actress known for playing
intimidating women was one of the key
Inspirations for Designing Cruella
Deville bankhead's influence didn't stop
there though in the same Los Angeles
Times piece Cruella's voice actor Betty
Lou Gerson reflected that in the first
recording session they told me to see
what I could come up with the first
voice I tried sounded a bit like
Tallulah Bankhead everybody said that's
it don't change it clearly Disney's
iconic take on the character of Cruella
Deville owes a massive tip of the hat to
Bankhead and it's nice to know that the
inimitable movie star is still
terrifying kids to this day even if they
have no idea who she is
the 2008 Pixar classic Wally wears its
homages to Classic Cinema on its sleeve
and one of Wally's more explicit
references to the movies can be found in
the principal villain one who film fans
will be sure to recognize Auto may be
designed to look like a steering wheel
but the robot's gigantic glowing red
circle makes it perfectly apparent that
it's supposed to evoke HAL 9000 the
villainous computer from 2001 A Space
Odyssey the two carry similar designs as
well as a shared determination to enact
their own agendas over the well-being of
their human superiors
Auto's connection to 2001 becomes even
more explicit in the climactic showdown
between the captain and Otto which
employs the Richard Strauss composition
also sprach zarathustra that Strauss
piece of course was also used to
immensely memorable effect in 2001 A
Space Odyssey Auto does however depart
from Hal in one aspect Hal was voiced by
Douglas rain and was meant to carry a
more human quality than even the movie's
Flesh and Blood characters open the pod
bay doors hell
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that
conversely Otto is voiced by Macintosh
Apple's text to voice software this
gives Auto the most lifeless voice out
of all of Wally's cast giving Auto
unique qualities compared to Hal ensures
that this Wall-E villain can work as a
standalone entity for younger viewers
and in the process make the character
more than just a meaningless parody of
2001.
the alien antagonists in 2005's Chicken
Little are fluffy teardrop shaped
Critters who look pretty much
tailor-made to be sold at your local
Disney Store however these aliens don't
reveal their true forms until chicken
Little's final moments up until that
point these otherworldly visitors lurk
inside large robots that move around on
Long mechanical legs older viewers of
course will take one look at these
machines and realize they have more than
a passing resemblance to the antagonists
of H.G Wells The War of the Worlds in
Wells seminal work the Alien Invaders
move around in giant machines known as
tripods in the book Wells describes the
tripods as higher than many houses
striding over the young pine trees a
walking engine of glittering metal
striding now across the Heather
articulate ropes of Steel dangling from
it
the same description pretty much matches
chicken Little's own mechanical aliens
this homage proved timely for chicken
little too given that Steven Spielberg's
War of the Worlds also debuted in 2005
placing the tripods firmly back in the
public consciousness
The Lion King's villain scar doesn't
exactly hide the fact that he's evil his
contempt for Simba is palpable in their
earliest conversations and he relishes
the chance to throw his own brother
Mufasa off allege to his death but in
case anyone in the audience doesn't
quite understand the full extent of
Scar's cruelty The Lion King offers up a
few visual cues to cement his nefarious
nature during Scar's big be prepared
musical number the animators of The Lion
King made short a bask Scar and visual
parallels to contemporary Nazi
propaganda Nazi imagery is Rife
throughout the entirety of be prepared
including Scar's hyena henchmen marching
in a goose step formation while scar
looms above them an arrangement echoing
how Adolf Hitler would appear at
military parades and rallies the beams
of light surrounding scar during be
prepared also evoke the lighting devices
used at Nazi rallies thus creating a
very a creepy image of a feline fuhrer
the idea to tie scar into Nazi imagery
came about incidentally through an
animator doodling scar as Hitler this
throwaway picture inspired the visual
team Behind The Lion King to create
nazi-related visual parallels all
throughout the be prepared sequence the
result was a sequence that easily
reaffirmed the character's evil nature
while also creating some of the movie's
most striking imagery
with so many Spider-Man movies out there
there are a lot of Spider-Man villains
we're taking a look back at the many
many super villains that spidey's
battled against beware some gigantic
spoilers ahead stop the video now if
you're not up to date on every spider
movie The Amazing Spider-Man 2 is even
more than Spider-Man 3 before it an
overstuffed movie that banks on
interconnectivity to help Drive
excitement for a sequel that ultimately
never came at the time Sony Pictures was
attempting to push ahead with its own
Cinematic Universe with Spider-Man at
the heart when it didn't work we ended
up with Spider-Man in the MCU watching
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 today is mostly
an amusing exercise in seeing someone
try to build a universe that never quite
comes together Rhino is sadly a victim
of this crumbling effort the film had
Paul Giamatti playing a Russian gangster
in a mechanical Rhino suit and the actor
clearly relished chewing up as much
scenery as he possibly could in the role
sadly he only appears in a couple of
scenes he might have had more to do with
a hypothetical sequel but here he's
largely in example of a wasted
opportunity the version of Green Goblin
who shows up in The Amazing Spider-Man 2
is a perfect example of the film pushing
ahead for Universe building while
sacrificing any real sense of long-term
storytelling we've never met this
version of Harry Osborne before but
we're told he's got a connection to
Peter going back years we haven't seen
the tallest genetic illness is taking on
him but we're told it's bad and we
should care we haven't seen any real
development in terms of Green Goblin
Tech but were shown it all packaged and
ready for Harry to dive in it's a whole
lot of telling without any emotional
weight this lack of real investment
makes this the most forgettable version
of Green Goblin on the big screen so far
making Electro the primary villain of
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 was a good idea
on paper he's got cool powers that can
manifest themselves in interesting ways
visually and it was played by Jamie Foxx
who offered up a new version of the
character unfortunately it doesn't quite
work Fox seemed to do the best he could
with the material he had but the
character's motivations get lost in the
shuffle of of everything else the film
is trying to do by the time Electro is
somehow actually playing music with his
powers at the end of the film he's lost
any good will he had before
[Music]
Venom is a complicated character man
introducing him into any film as a
Spider-Man antagonist has the potential
to be very tricky business the way
Spider-Man 3 does it works fine as a
catalyst for the film's climax but
doesn't really let audiences get to know
this particular version of the villain
and how he works there's no time to dig
into what the relationship to the
Symbiote is or exactly why Eddie Brock
gives in so quickly or if there's any
real Humanity left in him this version
of Venom is pretty much just a fight
scene man that's a shame
[Music]
Spider-Man homecoming the first solo
Spider-Man Adventure in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is a great example of
a film that knows how to juggle multiple
villains without overwhelming the piece
while vulture does the heavy lifting as
the film's chief bad guy his crew back
at headquarters fits into the story in
an organic and entertaining way however
the tinkerer doesn't rank higher on this
list because he doesn't have that much
to do in the film he's the guy in the
chair manipulating Tech and
Communications behind the scenes while
the vulture does the fighting because of
that he's not a heavy hitter within the
film but he's certainly entertaining in
the space he's given homecoming manages
to breathe real life into him by making
him a nosy strange guy who's just happy
to have a gig where he can be a huge
tech nerd let me tell you about looking
at my phone oh sorry you left it out you
know I'm a curious person by Nature
the economy of Storytelling in
homecoming is so great that the film
manages to fit in not one but two
versions of the Shocker in the film he's
an employee of the vulture who's gifted
with gauntlets that emit tremendous
energy when they make contact with
someone or something it's enough to make
the character stand out in his few fight
scenes the first shocker relishes the
idea that he can have a self-given code
name and go around punching things with
his new toys you're out there wearing
that goofy thing lighting up cars
calling yourself the Shocker the Shocker
a shock people what is this pro
wrestling yeah whatever old man when the
second chakra gets a hold of the
gauntlets Things become much more
business-like and the deliberate
calculated way in which he tries to pick
apart Peter Parker is actually rather
chilling together they present A
Portrait of a minor super villain that
adds plenty to the film while never
getting in the way of vulture's
Spotlight The Amazing Spider-Man wisely
started its new Spidey Universe by
picking a villain who'd only been hinted
at in the Sam Raimi films in the form of
a supporting character we've seen Dr
Kirk Connors before 4 but we'd never
seen him transformed into a monster by
his own scientific hubris and
Desperation the fact that the character
was in the Ramey films created a sense
of excitement among fans who were
finally going to get to see the lizard
while never quite feeling like the new
film was retracing the steps of the old
ones in The Amazing Spider-Man Dr
Connors takes on a certain kind of quiet
strangeness that permeates the early
scenes you get the sense that he's a man
who's thought far too much about things
he probably shouldn't be tinkering with
as his slow transformation Begins the
character becomes even stranger creating
a villain who's both threatening and
sympathetic
[Music]
the decision to make the Sandman a major
villain in Spider-Man 3 is an
interesting one particularly when you
consider all the other things the film
is trying to do with Peter Parker's
emotional Journey the decision to make
him the guy who killed Uncle Ben off
screen in the first film complicates
this in ways that neither the film nor
the Spider-Man Mythos really need
despite this this version of the Sandman
works because of the parallels the film
draws between him and Peter they're both
men with strange Powers they didn't ask
for pushed into darkness by
circumstances beyond their control and
hoping to atone for their past mistakes
Thomas Hayden Church plays the character
with real hearts and his final scene is
one of the most powerful moments in a
flawed film
I'm not asking you to forgive me
I just want you to understand
[Music]
Spider-Man 3 could have been a film
entirely about the rise of a second
Green Goblin in parallel to Peter Parker
wrestling with the Venom symbiote and it
would have still been a jam-packed movie
as it is we got a film that attempted to
juggle three different villains and
crammed them all together into a final
fight scene so Harry Osborne's final
journey in the Spider-Man trilogy gets
crammed in too still Perry's decision to
become the second Green Goblin in an
effort to avenge his father and then to
seek heroic Redemption is a rewarding
one it doesn't always work particularly
when Harry has to turn on a dime between
Hiro and villain in various scenes but
the two preceding films add emotional
weight to a weaker script
Willem Dafoe is having so much fun in
the role of Green Goblin years before
character actors would begin competing
for super villain roles left and right
and his sense of instant Joy at being
immersed in the comic book world is
infectious the foe has to transform into
full super villain mode almost instantly
and somehow he brings it to life
flawlessly
[Music]
what do you want
to say but you won't to do what you
can't
he does so even in spite of the film's
shortcomings and its treatment of the
character something that's particularly
obvious in a costume design the decision
to forego an expressive face for the
character and instead feature a Fang
bearing mask might have made sense in
2002. unfortunately watching the film
today it makes the scenes with
Spider-Man and the Goblin look a bit too
much like action figures yelling at each
other even in those moments though
defoe's voice carries the performance if
you didn't watch the intro this is where
the big spoilers happen so turn back now
Spider-Man far from home had to follow a
lot of different very tough acts just
one of which was Michael Keaton's
performance as the vulture the decision
to make the next villain Mysterio
another newcomer to live action
Spider-Man was a welcome one even better
fans seemed to immediately support Jake
Gyllenhaal's cast in his Mysterio a guy
who creates allusions to disguise his
true intentions Gyllenhaal gets a lot of
meaty stuff to play with in the film
from the idea that he first presents
himself as a hero From Another Dimension
to the Revelation that he's a scorned
former employee of Tony Stark the early
more heroic scenes were great but the
turn is where Gyllenhaal really shines
once the gloves are off and he's in full
super villain mode he's having the time
of his life and so were we he doesn't
quite rise to the heights of the very
best live-action Spider-Man villains but
he's very close so much so that even
after far from home you can't help but
feel hungry for more of him
with a few notable exceptions Sam
raimi's Spider-Man films are often
defined by their aesthetic and
structural Devotion to the Marvel Comics
book they're based on the key to the
best of these films is the way in which
they know exactly how to deviate and win
with Spider-Man 2 we get the best of
both worlds and Dr Octopus he's a guy
who looks and moves exactly how we'd
expect the comic book version to move
and he has the added gravitas of a good
man corrupted by his own creation Alfred
Molina is Flawless as Dr octo Octavius a
scientist who's hoping to change the
world before his brain is infected by
the artificial intelligence in his
robotic extra arms after a horrible
accident riddled with guilt and grief
Molina plays the disintegration of the
character perfectly then manages to
guide him back to Redemption with the
same sense of vulnerability and delicate
emotional resonance it's a great
performance and a great comic book movie
Sometimes Spider-Man stories are at
their very best when they take a very
simple easy to follow metaphor and
translate it into the big bold Strokes
of a superhero story Spider-Man
homecoming is a story about Peter Parker
finding out his girlfriend's dad is a
jerk and the jerk is played to
Perfection by Michael Keaton there's so
much to love about the vulture and
homecoming from the look of the
character to the way Keaton plays him as
a working-class guy who got tired of
being pushed around there's no nonsense
here but there are tricky emotional
turns to make and Keaton manages them
all by being equal parts charming and
terrifying the scene in which he has a
private moment with Peter in his car is
among the best moments in any Spider-Man
pill
hey
would you save your life
nobody say
thank you even better the fact that his
character actually has a point about the
way regular people are pushed down in an
increasingly strange world only adds to
his impact it's a brilliant layered
performance that's going to be hard to
top
there's nothing quite like a good shuck
at the movies and while everyone loves
to see their Heroes live happily ever
after sometimes audiences need a
reminder that life isn't all sunshine
and Roses here are a few movies where
the villain actually wins the Star Wars
universe is no stranger to a villainous
Victory or two with warring space
factions trading constant blows back and
forth across various conflicts Rogue one
and Revenge of the Sith certainly end on
some downloads for example but the
series most iconic Dark Side Victory
came in the middle chapter of the
original trilogy following the first
film which left off on a death star
destroying High The Empire Strikes Back
Came Crashing back down to reality when
it opened with a crushing defeat of the
Rebel forces on Hoth while the movie
splinters at that point with various
characters heading off to do their own
thing the paths of the protagonists
ultimately lead back to Lando corazian's
floating Heaven of cloud city
unfortunately when Darth Vader and his
minions show up to karissian City things
quickly go south for pretty much
everyone Han Solo is tortured and used
to the test subjects for carbon freezing
leaving him in suspended animation
corician loses Cloud City to the Empire
meanwhile Luke is lured into a trap and
confronted with one of Cinema's greatest
ever twists needless to say there's no
doubt that Empire's final act as a home
run for Vader and the Empire from start
to finish
the 2008 film Valkyrie is inspired by
the failed assassination attempt made
against Adolf Hitler in the summer of
1944 by a cabal of German officers
aiming to overthrow the Nazi regime
Colonel Claus Von stauffenberg joins
Major General Henning Von tresco and a
member of other conspirators who set up
a plan to kill off the dictator and use
the reserve Army to maintain order and
establish themselves as the new
government from there they plan to use
their power to negotiate favorable peace
terms with the Allies who at that point
are on the clear path to Victory the
film follows the story just so they
actually unfolded with everything
seeming to move towards victory for Von
stauffenberg and his co-conspirators in
fact the movie does it so well it almost
makes you forget that you already know
what's about to go down but alas
Valkyrie is ruthlessly Tethered to
reality initially the assassination
comes tantalizingly close to success
with a planted explosives going off
successfully and operation Valkyrie
being put into action but before long
reports surfaced that Hitler survived
the explosion and from there the whole
plot collapsed says the movie ends with
Hitler still alive and the film's heroes
executed for treason which is about as
bad as things possibly could have gone
over the years Marvel Comics have seen
plenty of tragic endings and grisly
Cliffhangers but the MCU itself has
tended to prefer the good guys to come
out on top but this trend has recently
begun to change having kicked off in
Earnest when Captain America Civil War
putted the Avengers against one another
leaving a host of angry PTSD ridden
superheroes behind in the process this
slide downhill only sped up with Thor
Ragnarok an otherwise fun movie that
ended with Asgard destroyed and a small
handful of survivors setting out in
search of a new home but it was only
drawing Avengers Infinity war that
Marvel finally opened up a universe in
which the villains really can win the
Colossal crossover event finds the hero
struggling to rise up and defend the
universe against Thanos and his cronies
only for the Mad Titan to finally pull
off his cataclysmic finger snap and wipe
out half the universe in the process
[Music]
inevitable well much of Thanos says my
destruction was undone in Avengers end
game Infinity war was nonetheless so
focused on Thanos and his story but his
victory during the film's closing
moments was never anything but
inevitable
seven follows detectives William
Somerset and David Mills as they
investigate a series of murders by a
mysterious criminal who uses the seven
deadly sins as his calling card the
movie gained speed as a Duo and cover
the first five sins but before the last
two take place the murderer known as
John Doe turns himself into the
authorities while covered in the blood
of an unknown victim as the movie wraps
up the growing sense of impending doom
becomes practically unbearable though
directs bills and some assets to the
desert where he informs them that the
last two victims will be found of course
they're already present as doe confesses
to being envious of Mill's idyllic life
with his pregnant wife Tracy before a
box arrives on the scene containing
Tracy's head inside Mills then gives
into temptation and kills doe who
becomes the final victim of Wrath aside
from being messed up in so many ways
sevens plus is never in the hands of the
movie's protagonist with doe in total
control right up until the credits roll
Christopher Nolan's the Dark Knights
delivered more than just an outstanding
performance from a greatly missed actor
since Heath Ledger's Joker was also one
of the first superhero villains to have
his way with the hero from beginning to
end from the moment he enters that
dramatic opening High sequence says last
laughter in the filmed climax the
infamous DC villain easily steals the
show The Dark Knight revolves almost
entirely around the Joker schemes
against Gotham and Batman many of which
are pulled off without a hitch as a
result this second film in Nolan's epic
Trilogy leaves Rachel doors dead Harvey
Dent warped into Two-Face and killed
soon after Batman on the run after
taking responsibility for dense crimes
and the bad signal destroyed by
Commissioner Gordon see Madness as you
know is like gravity all it takes is a
little push and sure the Joker is
eventually apprehended and has this
nihilistic philosophy thoroughly
disproven by the people of Gotham at the
same time but everything else went off
about as well as he could have hoped
Christopher Nolan appears to have
something of a gift for letting the
villains win in this case you've got
Memento The Narrative follows Leonard
Shelby a man who suffers from memory
loss every five minutes this is a recent
Affliction that has been occurring ever
since two men assaulted and murdered his
wife after Shelby killed one of them the
other knocked him on the head and
escaped leaving him with his new mental
handicap Shelby is dead set on hunting
down the other man responsible for his
wife's death but played with a
short-term memory loss he is forced to
use tattoos and Polaroid cameras in an
elaborate system to remind himself of
what he discovers the movie is filmed in
both color and black and white sequences
showing different angles of perception
and giving a sense of bizarre confusion
that helps the audiences relate to the
film's hero except Shelby isn't the hero
as the movie concludes we find that he
has been psychically hunting down and
taking Vengeance on innocent people for
a year repressing this information
Shelby tampers with his own photographic
evidence allowing his condition to wash
all guilt away within the next few
minutes and permitting him to continue
his villainous Behavior
while Peter Jackson's film adaptation of
J.R.R tolkien's or inspiring Lord of the
Rings trilogy has many happy moments
during its run time the ending of the
first film The Fellowship of the Ring
isn't one of them as the film reaches
its Crescendo the fellowship has already
gone through the devastating loss of
Gandalf but things go from bad to worse
as the forces of Mordor close in on them
boramia kicks things off by Falling to
the lore of the ring and attempting to
take it from Frodo unsuccessful in
Repentance or Amir and the rest of the
heroes turn their attention to a sudden
attack of orihai soldiers sent by
Saruman to find the ring the attack
splits the group up with the villains
killing Boromir and successfully
carrying off the hobbits Marion Pippin
Frodo meanwhile leaves his Sam across
the river and the two begin to work
their way towards Mordor alone all in
all this ending is about as chaotic as
it gets and doesn't lead to any one of
the protagonists actually getting their
way though Triumph flies ahead the truth
is that Fellowship is a movie about the
power of camaraderie that nonetheless
tears its characters away from each
other during its final moments and
that's about as Bleak As It Gets though
it's outside the Canon of the MCU and
doesn't have quite as catastrophic an
ending as Infinity War X-Men first Class
has another Marvel movie that doesn't
reward its Heroes with a happy ending in
this prequel to the original X-Men
movies the storyline jumps back in time
to the 1960s to explore the origin
stories of its heroes and villains in
particular the film focuses on the
development of the relationship between
professor Charles Xavier and Eric
lyncher which is the story of a profound
and meaningful friendship right up until
it isn't we everything else to be the
better man we already are
we're the next stage of human evolution
you said it yourself well the movie
itself brought a fresh spin to a
flagging franchise its story ended on a
dark note with the rise of an iconic
Marvel villain Magneto as the film
enters its final act the differences
between xaviors and Lynch's views of
mutant activism come to her head with
then show dramatically passing ways with
a critically wounded Xavier and his team
this sets him on a journey towards
becoming the franchiser's most notable
villain and begins a rivalry fated to go
down in history like Valkyrie life is
beautiful it's another story that ends
with the Nazis coming out on top this
classic Italian film was directed and
co-written by the incredibly talented
Roberto benini who also played the lead
role alongside nicoletti breske his wife
of nearly 30 years the first half of the
film is almost entirely light and
comedic as it follows Guido a Jewish
Bookshop owner in Italy who shamelessly
pursues the love of his life with a
little slapstick clowning and a lot of
Italian charm but things take a drastic
turn on the narrative jumps forward
several years to a Nazi occupied Italy
where Guido his wife and their son are
sent to a concentration camp once in the
camp the Bookshop owner uses his
incredibly resilient imagination to
tirelessly Shield his son from the
horrors around them convincing the young
boy that they're on a strange kind of
holiday despite the subject matter the
movie does actually build toward a happy
ending until in a gut-wrenching turn
Guido is gunned down by Nazis just as a
campus liberated and while Guido's sons
in a sense has preserved the loss of the
film's livable protagonist is
nonetheless a shocking note for the film
to end on
just like the classic 1949 George Orwell
novel on which it's based the movie 1984
is about as depressing as it gets from
the infamous thought police to the near
endless torture brainwashing and double
think this movie pretty much established
all the classic tropes of futuristic
dystopian horror the film is set in a
world with a single United superstate of
Oceania is run like a well-oiled
autocratic machine in which every move
and thought of its inhabitants are
scrutinize for any deviation from
government-approved Behavior the story
follows Winston Smith a supposedly loyal
worker at the ministry of Truth Smith
deviates from the rules when he meets
Julia and begins to secretly pursue an
affair with a daring fellow Thor
criminal of course government forces
proved much more powerful than two
people and the end of the movie shows
the couple as their caught and put
through a system of Rehabilitation in
which they are tortured and forced to
face their greatest fears in order to
break their rebellion and ensure their
future cooperation with the regime and
that's heartbreaking ending in the cafe
in which Julia and Winston Coley admit
they betrayed each other leaves no doubt
whatsoever that big brother has come out
on top
Spider-Man has faced nearly every member
of his Rogues Gallery during his
cinematic adventures but there are still
a few villains who have yet to make
their Silver Screen debut from killer
goblins to monstrous vampires to
um swarms of bees these are a few of
those villains
Craven the hunter is by far the most
infamous Spider-Man villain to have
never featured in a live-action movie
otherwise known as circuit cravenov this
obsessive Big Game Hunter first appeared
all the way back in 1964's Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 15. in this
story Craven is hired by his friend
chameleon to bring down Spider-Man
inevitably the hunter quickly becomes
the prey and Spider-Man has Craven both
arrested and deported this would Mark
the beginning of a long and storied
criminal career for Sergey cravenov who
has devoted his entire existence to
besting Spider-Man once and for all
considering Craven is such a prominent
member of Spider-Man's Rogues Gallery
it'll come as no surprise to find the
fans have been clamoring for him to show
up on screen for many years and he's
come pretty close too in 2021 Tom
Holland even told collider that
Spider-Man no way home director John
Watts originally intended for the third
MCU Spidey movie to feature Craven as
the main antagonist and now now it seems
that Craven is finally about to step
into the spotlight a solo film set
within Sony's Spider-Man universe has
been on the cards for a while now and in
2021 deadline reported that Avengers Age
of Ultron star Aaron Taylor-Johnson had
been cast as the notorious Hunter
himself you didn't see that coming
should all go to plan Craven the hunter
will land in theaters on January 13
2023.
Goblin villains will be very familiar to
fans of the Spider-Man movies Willem
Dafoe made comic book movie history as
Norman Osborne's Green Goblin in the
original Spider-Man while James Franco
played Harry as born in Sam raimi's
Trilogy taking the mantle of new Goblin
in Spider-Man 3. similarly Dane Dahan
played a goblin crazed Harry Osborne in
The Amazing Spider-Man 2. in the comics
however there are far more goblins than
the Green Goblin and many more people
have taken the mantle than Norman and
Harry Osborne perhaps the second most
well-known of these is the villain known
as the Hobgoblin six people have
operated under that name over the years
but the deadliest of all is Roderick
Kingsley debuting as the masked villain
in 1983's Amazing Spider-Man Vol 1
number 238 Kingsley is a billionaire
fashion designer who enters the criminal
underworld after acquiring and altering
Norman Osborne's Goblin formula it's
probably fair to say that audiences are
probably over the green Goblin by now
despite Willem dafoe's dramatic return
in Spider-Man no way home nevertheless
the hobgoblins movie debut could provide
a refreshing Twist on a fan favorite
villain
otherwise known as the spot Jonathan own
first appeared in 1985's Peter Parker
The Spectacular Spider-Man Vol 1 number
98 a scientist in the employee of
Kingpin own creates a strange black
portal while attempting to recreate the
powers of the vigilante hero cloak it
soon becomes clear that own has gained
the ability to open these portals and
Traverse physical space via the
so-called spot world own subsequently
names himself the spot and embarks upon
a criminal career the spot's unique
costume and strange abilities make him a
more visually arresting villain than
most suitably he's featured in a number
of stories beyond the comic book
Universe including Spider-Man the
Animated Series and the 2017 Spider-Man
show it's possible he'll be popping up
on the Silver Screen sometime soon too
as according to Murphy's Multiverse the
spot could be a key Baddie in the
upcoming animated sequel Spider-Man
across the spider-verse this could
literally not get any weirder since the
comic book version of own is a close
Ally of Kingpin who was the main
antagonist and into the spider-verse
it's easy to see how he might fit into
Miles Morales story and how the spot's
interdimensional Powers could provide an
intriguing slant on the original movie's
multiversal antics
the inheritors are a team of super
villains best known for their role in
the original spider-verse story arc and
its follow-up spider gedden each member
of this clan of totem hunting vampires
has dedicated their life to hunting down
spider people across the Multiverse and
consuming their Essences a number of
inheritors have battled Spider-Man and
his other selves but the two most
prominent are Moreland and Karn Moreland
is arguably the deadliest and scariest
member of the inheritors having killed
and consumed a whole heap of spider
people during his so-called great hunt
Carn meanwhile is living in Exile during
his first appearance after he hesitated
on a mission to capture the master
Weaver who controls the all-powerful web
of life and Destiny karn's mother was
struck down and killed as a result Karn
was exiled until he could prove his
return a task he attempts to accomplish
throughout the first spider-verse
storyline as the main antagonists of the
comic book version of spider-verse it
seems strange that the inheritors had
nothing to do you with Spider-Man into
the spider-verse still with two
follow-ups planned for that movie who
knows what the future has in store for
these Dimension hopping ghouls
silver Sable is one of those Spider-Man
characters who can act as an ally or an
enemy of the wall crawler depending on
what each story requires born Sylvia
sablinova this highly skilled mercenary
was introduced in 1985's Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 265 in which she
leads the Vigilante team of soldiers
known as the wild pack although she is
collaborated with a number of
superheroes over the years including
Spider-Man silver Sable has still played
the role of antagonist every now and
then although sablenova has yet to star
in a Spider-Man movie The Character was
once destined for the big screen in 2017
Sony announced that production had begun
on silver and black a feature film
following the adventures of sable and
black cat another morally ambiguous
Spider-Man friend in foe sadly the
project wasn't destined to last and
director Gina Prince bithwood eventually
revealed that Sony were considering
offering the story to Disney plus having
previously decided to give each
character their own movie Project a few
months later Prince bithwood told Looper
that she'd been preoccupied with her
work on the Netflix movie The Old Guard
but that she was planning to re-engage
with the silver Sable and Black Cat
Project at some point still Marvel fans
shouldn't expect to see Sable gracing
the Silver Screen in the near future
the villain known as Mr negative is a
more recent addition to Spider-Man's
Rogues Gallery first hitting the page in
2007's Free Comic Book Day The Amazing
Spider-Man his true name isn't known but
the man who became Mr negative was once
a Chinese gangster captured by the Crime
Boss silvermane and forced to undergo an
experimental drug procedure this process
gave him control over the light force
and dark force two forms of extra
dimensional energy that are more
commonly wielded by mutants and Magic
users the experiment also split the
gangster's mind into two forming the
Martin Lee Persona a philanthropist who
works with the homeless as well as Mr
negative himself the evil crime Lord at
the head of the inner demons street gang
Mr negative has played a prominent role
in Spider-Man's stories in recent years
but one of his most famous occurs in the
Marvel's Spider-Man video game in which
he wages a war against Kingpin and
Norman Osborne for control of New York
what are you doing to me
giving you a new perspective obviously
Mr negative isn't exactly a stalwarts of
the live-action Spider-Man movies but
his homeless charity Feast appears in
Spider-Man no way home so Never Say
Never
despite being nowhere near as well known
as Spider-Man's A-list Villains The
Jackal is actually one of Peter Parker's
oldest foes in 1965 The Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 31 introduced
readers to Miles Warren a professor at
Empire State University Who develops A
desperate infatuation with the students
Gwen Stacy after Stacy is killed by the
Green Goblin Warren blames Spider-Man
for her death adopting The Jackal Alter
Ego in order to get his revenge the
jackal's true identity was actually
something of a Twist in the original
comic books his villainous Persona
didn't emerge until 1974's The Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 129 with his
true identity revealed a year later in
number 148 in subsequent years the
Jackal has fought Spider-Man on a number
of occasions but his most notable
contribution is the creation of Clone
copies of Spider-Man such as Ben Reilly
who eventually became the Jackal himself
as such The Jackal has taken on a
starring role in some of Spider-Man's
most famous and Infamous story lines
including the clone saga and spider
Island
here's a pitch for you an Australian
with a knack for hurling boomerangs Dons
A Goofy costume and turns to a life of
crime joining up with several super
villain teams in the process think
you've heard this one before well this
isn't actually the origin of DC's
Captain Boomerang or at least it's not
just the origin of DC's Captain
Boomerang this is the story of Frederick
Myers AKA Boomerang DC's take on a
boomerang wielding criminal preceded
Marvels by six years with the latter
hitting the scene in 1966's Tales to
astonish volume 1 number 81 and it's
also probably fair to say that Marvel's
Boomerang is far less renowned than his
distinguished competitor Myers is an
ex-professional baseball player known
for his strong pitching arm who was
drafted into the employ of the
hydra-adjacent group known as the secret
Empire his new task Masters outfitted
him with special weapons and conferred
upon him the code name Boomerang more is
a joke than anything else after the end
of the Empire Myers decides to become a
freelance assassin and in this role he
has joined the ranks of pretty much
every team of super villains to have
ever existed sadly considering DC's
Captain Boomerang has recently been
adapted into live action for both
Suicide Squad movies it doesn't seem
likely that Marvel will be trying out
their own Boomerang anytime soon
let's just get one thing clear here yes
this is absolutely a man made of bees
better known under the pseudonym swarm
Fritz Von Meyer was a Nazi scientist who
stumbled across a colony of mutant bees
after the end of World War II Von Meyer
attempted and failed to control these
bees who consumed him alive and absorbed
him into their hive mind this not only
merged their consciousnesses but also
gave him the ability to control them at
will all of this is explained in
Champions Volume 1 Number 15. a story in
which swarm takes on a team of Heroes
including Angel Black Widow Ghost Rider
Hercules Iceman and Dark Star since then
however Von Meyer and his bothersome
bees have become a stalwart enemy of
Spider-Man more recently in Ant-Man Vol
2 he is teamed up with Scott Lang to
take down the buglords who are exactly
what they sound like as you might have
guessed swarm isn't exactly the most
serious comic book villain out there
indeed his latest stories have been a
lot of fun often leaning into the
characters Arch silliness if ever a
future Spider-Man movie needed a
colorful and amusing secondary
antagonist to stir up trouble on the
side swarm would be just the horrific
mass of bees for the job
Jackson wheel aka Big Wheel is one of
Spider-Man's weirdest foes first
appearing in 1978's The Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 182 wheel is a
corrupt businessman who hires the
villainous engineer known as the
tinkerer to create a massive deadly mono
wheel that will help him to defeat his
rival rocket racer their Feud soon
brings the big wheel into the path of
Spider-Man sparking a rivalry that would
last well not very long at all wheel
actually disappears at the end of the
very next issue and has only returned a
few times mostly as a joke character he
is also dabbled in super heroics every
now and again and even his more recent
acts of Mischief have been half-hearted
at best big wheel has yet to turn up in
a live action adaptation of Spider-Man's
Adventures which you probably knew
already because who wouldn't have
remembered Andrew Garfield fleeing a
huge wheel in The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
still it's probably fair to say that
this guy needs to join the MCU ASAP cast
some highly prestigious A-list actor
throw him into battle against Peter
Parker and watch those box office
numbers soar
James Bond wouldn't be half the Spy he
is if he didn't have some killer
villains to square off against
1962 he's been facing down some of the
toughest bad guys in movie history we're
here to give you a glimpse of what they
look like today
from Le Chief to Hugo Drax
in the 25th the Bond film no time to Die
the villainous and mysterious saffin
will be played by Rami Malik Malik is
best known for playing protagonist
Elliot Alderson in the television series
Mr Robot and Freddie Mercury in the film
Bohemian Rhapsody he's been active since
the early 2000s playing small roles in
shows like 24 and Gilmore Girls and
films like Night at the Museum Mr Robot
was the launch pad he needed and it
appears Malik will only continue to
climb higher in Hollywood
Kristoff vaults's breakout role arrived
in 2009 when he blew audiences away as
SS officer Hans Landa and Quentin
Tarantino's and glorious bastards vaults
went on to secure major roles in movies
like Django Unchained and eventually
2015's Specter Waltz is the latest actor
to play Ernst Stavro blofeld a recurring
Bond villain played officially by five
different actors over six decades in
this continuity blofeld is actually
Bond's adoptive brother who believes
Bond supplanted his position as favored
son
blofeld is the head of the global
criminal organization's Specter which is
secretly responsible for the events of
the previous three films you killed them
if I did
vaults has continued to act since
Specter having appeared in a wide
variety of films including Elita battle
Angel The Legend of Tarzan and
downsizing vaults will reprise his role
as blofeld in 2020's bond installment no
time to die
Javier bardem's first work as an actor
happened early he began acting as a
child in 1974 and went on to appear in
many movies throughout the 1990s and
2000s culminating in his star-making
turn as Psychopathic killer Anton sugar
in 2007's No Country for Old Men
this led to bigger roles including Raul
Silva in the 2012 Bond film Skyfall
Silva is a former MI6 agent who was
brutally tortured after M traded him to
the Chinese government and returned for
six captured agents Skyfall sees him
become a cyber terrorist out for bloody
revenge on M following Skyfall Bardem
has continued acting most prominently
playing the mysterious male lead in
Darren aronofsky's mother and Armando
Salazar in Pirates of the Caribbean Dead
Men tell no Tales
Matthew amelrique started acting in
1984's favorites of the Moon and his
most notable performances pre-bond are
his roles in the diving bell and the
Butterfly and Munich in 2008 Amal reek
made his bond debut as the villainous
Dominic Green in Quantum of Solace green
is an environmentalist entrepreneur who
secretly works for the mysterious
organization known as Quantum this evil
Collective is buying up Olivia's supply
of fresh water creating a monopoly that
will make green exponentially richer at
the expense of the Bolivian people
amalrique has remained very active as an
actor appearing in movies like Venus and
fur and shows like Wolf Hall among many
other credits
Mass Mickelson enjoyed worldwide
recognition for his role as Le Chief and
Casino Royale a mathematical genius with
Chief finances various terrorist groups
But ultimately loses their money in
Risky Investments this forces him to set
up a high-stakes poker game in an effort
to compensate for his losses Bond enters
the game hoping to prevent Le Chief from
paying back his debtors and force him
into seeking protection from MI6
Mickelson's acting career exploded in
the wake of Casino Royale the years
since have seen him take on high profile
roles such as casilius and Doctor
Strange and Dr Hannibal Lecter in the
celebrated television series Hannibal
Stevens has enjoyed a robust career in
acting since 1992 including performances
in Twelfth Night and the title role in
the 2000 TV movie adaptation of The
Great Gatsby he assumed the role of bond
antagonist and Die Another Day as Gustav
Graves a British billionaire with a dark
secret Stevens has remained very active
since Die Another Day most notably he
starred as Captain Flint in Black Sails
and as John Robinson in the 2018
reimagining of Lost in Space
Scottish actor Robert Carlisle started
acting in the 1990s taking on roles in
films like Trainspotting and the full
monty in 1999 he faced James Bond as the
villainous Reynard and The World is Not
Enough Raynard previously survived an
assassination attempt by MI6 but it left
a bullet in his brain now he seeks
revenge against MI6 by any means
necessary since his turn in the World is
Not Enough Carlisle has taken on a
variety of notable roles in film and
television he appeared as Dr Nicholas
rush in Stargate Universe portrayed
Rumpelstiltskin and once upon a time and
took on the role of prime minister
Robert Sutherland on the television
series cobra
Welsh actor Jonathan price started his
career on the British stage of the 1970s
and later moved to film with projects
like Brazil in 1997 price played the
bond villain Eliot Carver and Tomorrow
Never Dies Carver is a sociopathic media
Baron who plans to expand his Empire by
inciting a war between China and the UK
price has enjoyed a number of Stellar
roles since Tomorrow Never Dies he's
earned a particular Acclaim for his
performances as Pope Francis in the two
popes Weatherby swan in the Pirates of
the Caribbean movies and the High
Sparrow in Game of Thrones
before playing a bond villain Bean
performed Shakespeare on stage and
earned roles in films like Patriot Games
and black beauty in 1995 he took on the
role of Alec trevalian a fellow MI6
agent and close friend to James Bond in
Goldeneye the two conduct a mission
together in which trevalian is seemingly
killed but nine years later it's
revealed that he staged his death and
betrayed MI6 to become a crime Lord
Bean has continued to have a very
successful career Landing roles in The
Lord of the Rings trilogy National
Treasure and Game of Thrones Robert
Dobby has enjoyed a rich acting career
since the 1970s appearing in such
Classics as The Goonies and die hard in
1989 he starred as International drug
lord Franz Sanchez and Licensed to Kill
Sanchez's master plan is quite simple
really he wants to continue to sell
drugs on a massive scale and corrupt or
kill anyone who gets in the way
after playing a bond villain Dobby has
continued acting in a wide variety of
projects including Predator 2 Stargate
Atlantis Criminal Minds The Expendables
3 and more
Dutch actor yiron krabe began acting in
the 1960s enjoying particular
distinction from his work and soldier of
orange and the Fourth Man the late 80s
saw him play a string of villainous
roles which brought him widespread
Acclaim most prominently General koskov
in the 1987 Bond film The Living
Daylights koskov is a brilliant Soviet
General who feigns neutrality in the
Cold War in reality he plans to misuse
Soviet funds to buy a large supply of
opium and trade it for arms kerbe went
on to play many more famous villains
including Johnny Franco and The Punisher
Charles Nichols and The Fugitive and
even Satan himself the 1999 TV movie
Jesus
he continues to act and is also an
accomplished painter
Joe Don Baker started his acting career
with parts in westerns like wild Rovers
going on to earn major attention for his
roles in Charlie Varick and Walking Tall
in 1987 Baker played the war obsessed
arms dealer Brad Whitaker in The Living
Daylights baker has continued to act in
the Years following The Living Daylights
though the last decade did see him grow
considerably less active before this
slowdown Baker appeared in movies like
Congo and even returned to the bond
franchise he played the very different
role of Bond's Ally Jack Wade and
GoldenEye and Tomorrow Never Dies
prior to taking on bond Christopher
Walken earned a claim for his roles in
Classics like Annie Hall the Deer Hunter
and the dead zone in A View to a Kill he
played Tech Giant Max zorin who planned
to destroy Silicon Valley to eliminate
competition for his microchip business
after playing Max zorin Watkin has
maintained a very active career he's
appeared in Batman Returns Pulp Fiction
ants Sleepy Hollow Catch Me If You Can
and many other notable films walk-in is
also a frequent host of Saturday Night
Live where you likely best know him for
being in an unforgettable sketch with an
unforgettable line
guess what
I got a fever
and the only prescription is more
cowbell
Julian Glover has been acting since the
1950s taking on a wide variety of roles
and Productions including The Empire
Strikes Back equator mass and the pit
and the Avengers in 1981 Glover found
himself face to face with James Bond as
the villain Aristotle cristatos and For
Your Eyes Only cristatos appears to be a
respectable war hero and businessman but
is later revealed to be a heroine
Smuggler and double agent after playing
a bond villain Glover has continued to
have a very successful acting career
most prominently Glover played Walter
Donovan in Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade voiced aragog and Harry Potter
in the Chamber of Secrets and portrayed
Grand maester py cell in Game of Thrones
Michael Lonsdale has appeared in over
180 different films and television shows
however his most famous role is likely
still Bond villain Hugo Drax from the
1979 film Moonraker Drax is an extremely
wealthy businessman who owns a company
that builds space shuttles being rich
and Powerful has clearly gone to drax's
head as he wants to wipe out humanity
and restart Society with a few selected
humans using his spacecraft he and his
master race plan to orbit the planet
until toxins kill everyone below
Lonsdale continued to enjoy a rich
acting career post tracks notably he won
a Cesar award for his performance as
Luke in the 2010 film of Gods and Men
and remained active on screen until
2016. he passed away in September of
2020.
french actor Louis Jordon gained major
Acclaim for playing Suave roles in
French and American films working
closely with big names like Alfred
Hitchcock and Elizabeth Taylor in 1983
Jordon played the villainous Kamal Khan
and octopussy Khan an exiled Afghan
Prince starts out as a jewelry Smuggler
whose plans get bigger and deadlier when
he helps smuggle an atomic bomb into
West Germany after playing a bond
villain Jordan continued acting in film
and television until his retirement in
1992. in 2015 Jordon passed away at the
age of 93. Richard Keel played henchman
Jaws in the spy who loved me and
Moonraker Jaws is extremely strong and
Tall forcing Bond into creative
approaches when fighting him his most
striking feature however are his metal
teeth which can bite through even the
hardest Metals in an interesting plot
twist Jaws ends up undergoing a major
change of heart turning on his boss and
helping Bond defeat Drax Jaws even gets
a girlfriend in the end well
appears to us
Kiel continued acting after playing Jaws
appearing in roles like Mr Larson and
Happy Gilmore he passed away in 2014 at
the age of 74.
Kurt Jurgens filmography is extensive
before his bond days he starred in films
like the enemy below and the longest day
then in 1977 Jurgens took up the bond
villain mantle in the spy who loved me
playing the ocean obsessed Carl
Stromberg who plans to start a nuclear
war and start a new life for Humanity at
sea Jurgens continued acting after his
role in the spy who loved me with roles
in the Sci-Fi Sports drama Golden Girl
and the war film breakthrough his last
role was General Vladimir and the BBC
miniseries Smiley's people he passed
away in 1982 at the age of 66.
it's no surprise that the late
Christopher Lee played a bond villain
his impressive acting career contains
many villainous roles from Saruman in
The Lord of the Rings series to Count
Dracula and the hammer horror films in
1974 Lee took on the role of Francisco
scaramanga in The Man with the Golden
Gun an Infamous assassin with a famous
weapon scaramanga also has a flying car
and a secret Island to scaramanga it's
not about eliminating Bond it's about
besting him this is the part I really
like
Lee remained very active as an actor
leading up to his death in 2015 at the
age of 93. in addition to his work in
major franchises like the Lord of the
Rings and Star Wars in which he played
Count Dooku he also enjoyed a career as
a heavy metal vocalist
yafet Koto is the Sinister Dr kananga in
1973's Live and Let Die simultaneously a
dictator and a gangster kananga's plan
is to freely distribute heroin at his
restaurants bankrupt his competitors
then raise his prices Koto went on to
enjoy more major success as an actor
including his role in the NBC television
series homicide life on the street he's
also widely known as Parker an alien and
Alonso Mosley in Midnight Run
Baron samdi played by Jeffrey holder is
one of the most frightening bad guys in
the bond franchise appearing in 1973's
Live and Let Die he's a witch doctor of
the fictional Caribbean island of San
Monique who works for the main villain
Dr kananga outside of bond holder
enjoyed a stellar career as an actor
dancer musician and artist on both stage
and screen with roles in films like
Annie and Boomerang holder passed away
in 2014 at the age of 84. English actor
Charles Gray actually appeared in You
Only Live Twice as a different Bond
character but in 1971 he returned to the
franchise as the main villain Ernst
Stavro blofeld and diamonds are forever
this time blowfeld has physically
altered his henchmen to look like him
Bond must identify and stop the real
blofeld who plans on using a satellite
built out of diamonds to destroy the
world's arsenals gray continued acting
post blofeld playing roles like the
criminologist and The Rocky Horror
Picture Show and Mycroft Holmes in the
1984 TV series Sherlock Holmes he passed
away in 2000 at the age of 71.
Telly Savalas gained Fame for roles in
films like The Greatest Story Ever Told
The Dirty Dozen and Birdman of Alcatraz
then in 1969 Savalas portrayed Ernst
Stavro blofeld and On Her Majesty's
Secret Service blofeld is threatening
the world yet again in this movie this
time through biological warfare he
brainwashes women putting them into a
hypnotic state in which they distribute
bacterial agents capable of devastating
the world's agriculture after Bond foils
his plans blofeld kills Bond's wife
Tracy which furthers the feud between
the two epic rivals
sabalas continued to play big roles post
blofeld including starring in the
popular television series Kojak Savalas
remained active as an actor right up
until his death in 1994 at the age of
72.
and You Only Live Twice Ernst Stavro
blofeld is portrayed by British actor
Donald Pleasence who ended up creating
one of the most recognizable villains in
the entire bond series
his blofeld has a secret base hidden
inside a volcano where he dispatches
orders with his white cat in his lap
after bringing blofeld to life Pleasants
remained very active as an actor playing
notable roles in the Halloween franchise
Prince of Darkness and More in 1995
Pleasants passed away at the age of 75.
Adolfo Chelly specialized in playing
villains with a Cosmopolitan Edge it's
no surprise then that he played Emilio
Largo in Thunderball with such Panache
Largo's evil plan is to steal warheads
and blackmail NATO into paying him a
large sum of money lest he start
destroying major cities Shelley went on
to act in numerous roles post Largo
including the Borges and danger diabolic
and continued acting right up until he
passed away in 1986 at the age of 63.
Gert fruba played the title role of gold
obsessed madman auric Goldfinger in
Goldfinger one of the quintessential
Bond films the film's plot features
goldfinger's attempt to Rob Fort Knox in
order to drive up the price of gold and
also includes one of the most famous
lines in the franchise
[Music]
after his turn as one of the most iconic
Bond villains ever furuba continued to
have a rich acting career on stage and
Screen his roles in Chitty Chitty Bang
Bang and those Magnificent Men and their
flying machines saw him gain particular
Acclaim in very different genres musical
fantasy and comedy respectively he
passed away in 1988 at the age of 75.
even though he isn't the main villain of
the movie our job is one of the most
memorable parts of Goldfinger played by
Harold cicada his weapon of choice is
his hat which has a razor-sharp steel
rim odd job is terrifyingly good at
assassinating victims by hurling his hat
at high speed though our job was
cicada's first role as an actor after a
successful weightlifting career it
definitely wasn't his last he went on to
perform in Productions like Hawaii 5-0
impulse and dimension 5. cicada
occasionally spoofed his role as odd job
in later years most prominently by
appearing in a series of Vicks cough
syrup commercials he passed away in 1982
at the age of 62.
Lottie lenya played Rosa kleb a
high-ranking member of the mysterious
Specter organization in From Russia with
Love cleb one of the franchise's first
villains is remembered best for her
signature weapon poison tipped blades
concealed in the tips of her shoes
lenya was already a respected actor
pre-bond thanks to an acclaimed stage
career and roles in films like the Roman
spring of Mrs Stone
she was also an accomplished singer and
was inducted into the American Theater
Hall of Fame in 1979. two years later in
1981 she passed away at the age of 83.
Joseph Wiseman had the honor of playing
the first Bond villain Julius no in
1962's Dr No Julius no has a killer
outfit a complex backstory and an epic
underground layer where he plots to
start a war between the Russians and
Americans like so many Bond villains who
would follow him no also has a unique
physical trait prosthetic metal hands
wise men continued to act after his turn
as Dr No appearing in the Twilight Zone
Magnum PI MacGyver and more Wiseman
passed away in 2009 at the age of 91.
even the mcu's strongest and most
charismatic villains have weak spots of
their own through which the heroes wind
up gaining the upper hand and saving the
day from ironmonger to killmonger here
are the biggest weaknesses of these MCU
bad guys
the Marvel Cinematic Universe got its
start in 2008 with Iron Man which
introduced the world to Robert Downey Jr
as Tony Stark and laid the groundwork
for the next 10 years of genre defining
superhero movies as iconic as the first
Iron Man film is however we wouldn't
blame you for forgetting about Obadiah
stain the vicious opponent who
inadvertently pushed Tony to transform
from a brilliant but selfish arms dealer
into a world-saving self-sacrificing
hero stain was an old friend of Howard
Stark Tony's father and served as CEO of
Stark Industries after Howard's death
until Tony was able to take over despite
his fatherly demeanor stained coveted
Tony's role as the man in charge and he
wound up throwing in his lot with the 10
rings in an effort to get Tony out of
the pitcher and regain control of the
company stain simply was not content to
be Tony's mentor and second in command
especially when Tony's conscience
started cutting into Stark Industries
bottom line he hoped to seize back the
company from its idealistic CEO and he
created the Iron Monger suit to help him
do just that unfortunately for staying
the greed that motivated him to steal a
company was also what led to his
ultimate demise not only did he pause to
gloat rather than finishing Tony off his
rush to build his own Iron Man suit
without Tony's Brilliance backing it up
left him with a powerful but crucially
flawed design how'd you solve the icing
problem I see a problem
I will look into it that combination of
arrogance and greed along with an
unfortunate choice to open up his armor
to brag face to face put a quick end to
stain's career as a super villain
it's no secret that the children of Odin
could use quite a bit of family therapy
although each of them seems to struggle
with a different issue the all-father's
youngest son Loki wrestles with a Godly
inferiority complex that hit him against
his family and would come to threaten
not just the world but the entire
universe even before he learned that he
was actually the biological son of the
frost giant king laufi Loki felt like he
could never get out of his brother
Thor's Shadow so I am no more than
another stolen Relic locked up here
until you might have use of me why'd you
twist my work after learning the truth
of his Origins Loki's insecurity kicked
into overdrive he compensated by
attempting to get rid of his brother
entirely so that he wouldn't have to
compete with him anymore even though
Thor himself never saw Loki as anything
but a beloved brother that anger even
drove him to drop into the vast
emptiness of space rather than accept
his brother's Mercy after his first
defeat when Loki returned in The
Avengers it was as a puppet of Thanos
throwing in with the universe's most
evil villain in an effort to prove
himself Superior to his brother even
then the greatest opponent Loki faced
was his own self-doubt well self-doubt
and the Hulk over and over he attempted
to prove that he was worthy of something
he already had the love and respect of
his adopted family at first he acted out
in unhealthy and harmful ways in an
attempt to convince both his relatives
and himself that he didn't need anything
from them even though he obviously
yearned for their approval eventually as
he learned to accept that Thor had
always loved him just the way he was he
was able to work productively alongside
his brother instead of feeling
threatened by him just in time to be
taken out by Thanos in front of the
brother with whom he just made peace
better late than never
as a literal robot it's unsurprising
that the genocidal Ultron adhered pretty
stringently to rules of his own making
however his inability to compromise or
bend his rigid views is what ultimately
led to his downfall in Avengers Age of
Ultron while that and the Hulk these bad
guys don't really do so well with him
huh a product of Tony Stark's
peacekeeping program which was
subsequently beefed up by the Mind Stone
ultron's core objective was to protect
the Earth from future threats
unfortunately for everyone after mulling
over his mission for a while Ultron
determined that the biggest threat to
Earth was in fact humans and he set
about attempting to eradicate them
the fixed mindset that sent Ultron on
his destructive path was also what
caused his end even after meeting
opposition from the vision an artificial
being created the same way Ultron
couldn't be reasoned with if Ultron had
been able to change his mind perhaps The
Avengers would have found a way to allow
him to exist
as it was ultron's single-mindedness
paved the way for his complete
Annihilation just like all of his
robotic creations
superhero movies might be popular but
they tend to be a hard sell when it
comes to critical acknowledgment every
now and then though one manages to break
through as an awards Contender because
it's simply too compelling to ignore
this was the case with black panther and
a big part of that film's success was
thanks to its villain Eric killmonger
unlike most Marvel movies which tend to
open with the hero's origin story black
panther started with killmongers and
from the moment we saw him as a child in
that opening scene he was incredibly
sympathetic in fact as the film
progressed The moviegoers in the
audience and even some of the film's
good guys had to admit that killmonger
was making a few good points these items
aren't for sale
how do you think your ancestors got
these you think they paid a fair price
or did they take it like they took
everything else t'challa himself
conceded that his father tachaka was
wrong about wakanda's policy of
isolation and that abandoning young Eric
had been a mistake yet rather than
cultivate the favor of the people
already inclined to agree with him
killmonger wound up pushing them away
with his uncompromising extremist views
while adopting a more measured approach
could have won him allies within wakanda
including possibly even t'challa
hillmonger's plan was to stoke civil
uprisings by flooding the world with
wakandan weapons his All or Nothing
approach to achieving his vision meant
that rather than finding an ally in the
king of wakanda he found an opponent and
the two wound up battling to the death
Loki spent his entire cinematic lifetime
struggling to dig out from under a hefty
pile of self-doubt and prove his
worthiness to his father his brother and
most of all himself his older sister
hella had the opposite problem in Thor
Ragnarok she was so convinced that she
should be ruling over Asgard that she
thought all she'd have to do was show up
and people would fall in line behind
their beloved new Queen granted she was
a formidable opponent as evidenced by
her ability to take out the Warriors 3
and the armies of Asgard single-handedly
still marching through the streets
taking out beloved second string Marvel
characters and sending all the other
asgardians into hiding doesn't really
endear you to the public no matter how
cool your giant wolf is in other words
she wasn't exactly greeted as a
liberator and her entitlement lulled her
into thinking she'd Prevail simply
because she thought she should
believe me I would love for someone else
to rule but it can't be you you're just
the worst hella's sense of superiority
kept her from winning anyone to her
cause with even her right-hand
Lieutenant abandoning ship when he
couldn't stomach any more of her actions
she could have relied on her legitimate
claim to the throne to win over the
asgardians but instead of working with
her brothers she blasted them into
Oblivion without even checking to make
sure they were gone for good leaving
herself wide open for them to team up
against her if she had taken the time to
actually interact with the people of
Asgard instead of terrorizing them or if
she'd collaborated with her brothers
instead of opposing them it may have led
to an Asgard that all three of Odin's
children could have lived in together
instead of one that had to be raised
into nothing
Carol Danvers faces a variety of
opponents in Captain Marvel but janrog
is by far the most Insidious he spends
most of the film pretending to be her
mentor and Ally but even when he's being
set up as Carol's friend there are hints
of Darkness lying beneath his friendly
surface
multiple times he attempts to diminish
her power under the guise of training
her accusing her of being too emotional
he pushes her to hold back rather than
develop her strength and discourages her
from exploring the limits of her powers
he claims this is for her own good to
teach her control but it's really
designed to keep her weak so that he can
hold the power in the relationship
gradually as Carol uncovers the truth of
who she is she begins to realize that
janrog's training was never meant to
help her instead he was giving her a
pair of metaphorical handcuffs holding
her back so that the cree can use her
for their own purposes Carol stepping
into her own power feels like a threat
to yonrog who wishes to keep her small
so that he can feel big important and
Powerful he even goes so far as trying
to win her over with the approval he's
been holding back once she realizes the
truth strip away the superpowers and
it's a story all too familiar for many
women who have been abused by insecure
men janrog's weakness doesn't have
anything to do with his physical
capabilities but everything to do with
how threatened he feels by a strong
woman it's an attitude that leads him to
getting blasted into a rock because once
Carol figures out what he's doing she
has no tolerance for it anymore
there isn't a single Marvel villain who
doesn't have some degree of hubris in
their character but no one displays this
trait more than Thanos whose plan to
eliminate half of all life in the
universe culminates in Avengers Infinity
war and Avengers end game Thanos is
convinced that what he's doing isn't
just right but necessary and that it's
up to him to set things on a path that
only he's allowed to determine no matter
the cost granted Thanos is incredibly
powerful and he actually does succeed
despite his arrogance
but in viewing himself and his plan as
inevitable Thanos doesn't ever consider
that there may be value in individual
lives teamwork and self-sacrifice he
views The Avengers as pests to be
swatted down rather than serious threats
and it never occurs to him that someone
could be willing to sacrifice everything
to preserve the lives Thanos wants to
take the Avengers fight their battle
knowing the odds are against them which
makes them willing to do whatever they
have to in order to earn their Victory
they are willing to sacrifice themselves
while Thanos is only willing to
sacrifice others the Mad Titan never
even considers that he might lose which
cracks open the door for exactly that to
happen
for the First Act of Spider-Man far from
home Quentin Beck seems like a pretty
good guy he's funny he's charming and he
seems like exactly the sort of smart and
nurturing Mentor figure Peter Parker is
looking for unfortunately he's also a
con man nursing a serious grudge against
his former employer Tony Stark and he's
decided that the whole world has to pay
for the wrong that was done to him to be
fair Tony Stark was probably a pretty
terrible boss to work for and absolutely
underestimated the technology back in
his crew used throughout the film Beck
has every right to be mad but the
lengths he goes to in drawing together a
group of similarly wronged ex-employees
and hatching a plan to destroy entire
cities in order to usurp Tony's Legacy
that goes a little Beyond leaving him a
bad review on Glassdoor this bitterness
pushes Mysterio to keep going way past
the time when he should have stopped it
leads him to keep attacking Peter with
his drones even after they start
malfunctioning which ultimately leads to
his death
[Music]